3:28 thank you next we go in-depth with
David Halberstam David Halberstam has
been writing for nearly 50 years first
as a newspaper reporter covering civil
rights and foreign affairs his coverage
of Vietnam one in the peel of fear at
age 30 he's produced 17 books including
the best-selling trilogy on power the
best and the brightest the powers that
be and the reckoning for the next three
hours you'll meet David Halberstam in
depth will take your calls and talk
about his writing career including his
latest book war in pharmacy David
Halberstam
as a writer I'm wondering about your
instinct since September 11th especially
since so many of the books that you have
done have been what people call first
drafts of history well I you know you
want to go with the events I mean it's
by chance the book that was out war in a
time piece was really the book that was
a pre mood to the events in effect why
was America napping in that period since
the end of the Cold War so it seemed and
I think is very germane I mean why were
we caught so much by surprise why was
our our agenda political and media so
trivial and that's what I try and
explore that the subtitle really could
be why American apt not unlike the John
Kennedy book why England slept but now I
have to start thinking of what do I do
next and what are you doing I mean I
observed a lot of reporting and I've
done some writing I did a piece for
Vanity Fair in a special issue on on
what it meant I mean not how the world
had changed on that one morning I mean
from a time of peace to a time of war I
did that I've done the introduction for
a collection of great magnum photos of
the day and I'm doing a piece on a
firehouse for Vanity Fair of firehouse
two blocks from us which lost 11 men all
the men who went down other than
really lost I mean heartbreaking so I'm
doing that and then I'm trying to figure
out whether it changed the direction of
my next book to something that connects
to this and I think I will I want to
introduce you to this program David
Halverson will be with us for three
hours in total we will be talking here
in our studio in Washington for about
the next 20 minutes and then we invite
your telephone calls and those calls can
come in on the topic of any of the many
books he's written or other pieces by
him that you've read and will tell you
how to get through to the program if you
live in eastern and central time zones
we've got a number that you can use and
those watching in the western half the
United States will have a separate line
and again you can begin dialing at any
time during the next few minutes but
we'll go to calls about 20 minutes from
now I want to turn to that Vanity Fair
piece that you referenced the special
edition that they put out on September
11th to read for two reasons so that
people who aren't familiar with the work
can get a sense of your writing but also
your observations you write we have
witnessed a turning point in American
history the beginning of what I think is
going to be one of the most challenging
of our geopolitical struggles because
the enemy is so difficult to do battle
with because he offers so poor target
for our high-technology weaponry and
because no small part of his strength is
his patience which he matches against
our innate impatience an inevitable
byproduct of a dynamic society
constantly in some sort of overdrive
since you've done so many studies of
modern America how prepared are we and
what do you think the ultimate success
of us doing battle with this sort of
enemy might be I I think in the long run
will do well I think we are ill-prepared
democracies really always are I think
they are slower to react I think
everybody now is you know looking and
finding fault with everyone else why
were the intelligence systems better why
weren't the security systems better why
don't our bombing runs against the
Taliban work better are our Special
Forces our Delta forces going in I mean
I think we forget that we were
ill-prepared at the time of Pearl Harbor
ill-prepared at the time of Sputnik we
the early experiences of American combat
troops in North Africa were not in fact
particularly good I mean
there is a learning curve and a growing
again and I think democracies and
particularly this one because we've
always been protected by our two oceans
were slower than both but I have great
faith in in the democracy particularly
once it focuses and gives high priority
on his agenda to it I agree I have great
faith in this country and I think that
to Tollett Ariens always underestimated
us I mean Hitler and the Imperial
Japanese thought we were soft and
decadent II the leaders of the Soviet
Union thought we were soft and decadent
mr. Khrushchev said he would bury us
issues his son teaches at my daughter's
college in Providence Rhode Island now
mr. Milosevic told our diplomats that we
were too soft and could not take death
and and bin Laden has said the same way
but I think our priorities are different
we just do it a little more slowly once
we put the full resource of this country
at war this is not a country you want to
tinker with or toy with this is a very
powerful very resilient country before
we dig into some of the specifics of
your books must tell me how it all got
started you mean when I left college and
all of the look the only thing I was
really ever good at was it was
journalism I I went from public high
schools and we grew up in first in New
Yorker area in New York area then we
followed my father when he went back in
the service to army bases in Texas and
even the Mayo Clinic I've got a little
cut here my father was a doctor and
before he went overseas were in the Mayo
Clinic and when I played hockey at the
age of about 9 or 10 and went on my chin
about the second time I got sewn up at
the Mayo Clinic as a little sticky
little scar there and then Winsted
Connecticut and we went and then in
public schools then Harvard and I had a
learning disability I was it turns out
was a very bad student I probably my
grades averaged out to a C or below but
I was good at one thing the
undergraduate daily newspaper I was
managing editor the Harvard Crimson and
by instinct it came easily and naturally
where's the kind of learning disability
med learning in that abstract learning
large textbooks large lecture halls were
hard line I can still see my attention
span loading out the window of those
lecture halls I graduated in 1955 I
wanted to be a journalist it was I
thought it was the one thing I really
could do it was a year after Brown
versus Board of Education there was a I
thought the South would be interesting
Mississippi the most interesting because
it would be the monstre concert and I
was hired to work on a new paper in
Jackson and Jackson Mississippi I got
down there the man who hired me and
turned out didn't even work for the
newspaper but I ended up on the smallest
daily in Mississippi in West Point
Mississippi in the northeast hill
country I did that for about a year then
went for four very happy years on the
Nashville Tennessee in which I think was
the best paper in the south in the civil
rights movement where I was taught and
worked with wonderful colleagues a great
graduate school from me then went to the
New York Times where I was hired by the
great editor journalist of an era the
Scotty Reston went there joined the Pape
papers a day after John Kennedy's
election 40 41 years ago when very
didn't do terribly well in Washington
didn't have a real job I didn't get
traction but they said well he's young
and sing on me covers a civil-rights
will send him to Africa the Congo was
blowing up I became six months from
covering police Bend in in in Nashville
I was covering the biggest story
overseas in the breakdown of the order
in the Congo and almost won the Pulitzer
Prize there one year I I think I was
runner-up to walter Lippmann and then
here a year that and I went to Vietnam
as the first New York Times full time
correspondent and I think it was summer
1962 39 years ago it's interesting
there's one little thing there and that
is when I was at 27 28
in order to sample the tensions and
confrontations of our time I had to go
12,000 miles away to Saigon and now late
in my life almost 40 years later they
have struck they have come home to
within 5 miles of where I live
in New York City so and could you have
ever expected that happening not then I
mean gradually more recently there's
been pretty evidence that there were no
immunities and that terror would hit
terrorism would hit in New York I mean a
major American city and the most likely
one would be New York why did you make
the transition to books well I always
liked the idea of writing books in my
heroes had always been people like
Theodore White and John Gunther I
thought there was sort of a permanence a
little bit I don't I don't think any
writers ever immortal but there's a
little less there's a little more
immortality the book writing a little
more permanence a little more sense that
what you have done lasts a little bit
longer and doesn't go out wrapping fish
and so I saw that and I thought that
would be I'm a Teddy White had done
those wonderful early books fire in the
ashes and then the making of the
president when I was younger and I think
one of the things that also really
affected me was being in Vietnam I mean
I had a very good run there the paper
that I worked for The Times it was
really very good to me but you came away
with some of the frustrations of being a
daily journalist from there you were
nice enough to send I think you're very
earliest ever story
he had 40 years ago it's a novel yell
efforts I wrote two novels that's the
first one and it's okay I mean I wrote
it as a it's based on a true event in
his little town in Mississippi and it's
okay I what I was the process of doing
was finding out that I wasn't a novelist
I have to show the photograph on the
back and it depicts these retro hits
enough I think on 25 years old when that
pictures taken but you moved from novels
and moved to what style how would you
describe what it is you try to do with
your serie I write nonfiction journalism
reportage that has gradually morphed
into being history I'm now I'm really a
contemporary historian as much as
anything else now one of the really nice
things that's
been to me late in my career I was
elected rather elite group to something
called the Society of American
Historians it's elective it's elite and
I'm there with people like Arthur
Schlessinger a great historian and a
really wonderful man he used to give me
those C pluses so it's very nice
late-blooming victory for me now people
are so familiar with the best and the
brightest that you wrote an earlier book
in the midst of Vietnam called the major
quagmire I I may have been the person I
mean I now they're talking I you know
the question of whether Afghanistan and
dealing with the Taliban is going to be
a quagmire but I believe I'm the person
who put the phrase quagmire into usage I
mean it was an early that book was
written in 1964 and came out in early
1965 and it really was a pretty
pessimistic account of what was
happening I had a little fun with this I
have to tell you we picked up this copy
from a local public library and one of
your readers was writing was arguing
with you I'm sure he was in the in the
margins you're leaving a lot of people
that you know being a dissenter on
Vietnam were pessimist was not a was not
a popular thing there there's it's come
a long way now I mean 40 years later 37
years later it's okay to be more
critical of Vietnam that book was banned
from the USIA
library in Saigon when it first came out
it was the American authorities said
that it was in effect a seditious book
and what was her reaction to that at the
time I was not surprised I was taking so
much heat and abuse from the government
John Kennedy who had been president it
asked the publisher of the New York
Times to pull me from there and transfer
me to Paris or London and Lyndon Johnson
it took time off when he was president
from his you know are the considerable
duties as president to be Minister of
truth and he called Neil Sheehan my
young colleague and caused Neil and me
traitors to our country and to Philip
Bob Sherwood a writer
we were traitors to our country so by
then I was used to getting sort of
beaten up a little bit the best in the
brightest I was surprised and one of
these anniversary editions to learn that
in some ways the godmother of the best
and the brightest is the woman that
people in politics think of as the
neoconservatives injector well I don't
know that I'd called her a midge Decker
I wouldn't call her the godmother of the
book because I don't think she is but
she has suggested the article that
became the gern that became the book I
had come back from Vietnam in 67 very
pessimistic 1968 appeal recall was that
really you know classic year in America
where everything where all hell broke
loose Lee the challenge to the war the
Tet Offensive the assassination of
Martin King Robert Kennedy the
Democratic convention in Chicago which
went into the streets I covered all that
for harper's magazine when it was over I
really was at loose ends in November and
midge dektor had suggested she was a
colleague at harper's McGeorge Monday
and I thought that's a good idea you
know this allegedly brilliant Dean of
Harvard when I was there and if he were
so brilliant you know why were he and
the others the architects of this
tragedy so I began a piece for Harper's
Magazine that became this long long
piece 1915 20,000 words about him but
about the others and I think there's a
phrasing that they swept into office the
best and brightest of a generation and
out of that came eventually night when I
was finished I called my editor one
system magazine piece I called my editor
Jim Silberman had a and Random House and
said this is a book and I that became my
job to the next three or four years it
is also a classic study in the way that
you work would you talk a little bit
about your research style well I'm
really and there are people out there
that are document reporters I mean for
instance ifdawn worked on documents he
had terrible hearing and he didn't like
going to press conferences because he
couldn't hear soluz great documents man
and other people work brilliantly off
libraries may I'm a journalist so I'm a
reporter so I go and interview people
when I started that book
you know how and why we went to war in
Vietnam I thought you know can I do it I
know who'd be first questions who might
do it better and I thought well if my
friend Bernard fall had not been killed
in Vietnam clearly because he was both
journalist and historian he might have
done it better he was a wonderful man he
had more root rooted on that subject I
was a newcomer / journalist in those
days and none of that women my work at
Harper's had gone but are going from
daily journalism to three or four years
in Harper's writing magazine piece so
the intellectual level and I thought the
literary level was beginning to go up
and I thought what if I do this for
three or four years four years and if I
do two and a half years of legwork just
interviewing I do two interviews a day I
will have enough great material that I
can get a wonderful book and I thought
well I write as well as most
contemporary historians and it's a great
subject and I have access to people
because I'm in meshed in it and and I
can do this I mean you know why not me I
mean I can you know actually do it and I
can literally do it and I'm going to
give it four years there's nothing else
I want to do and need to do it's an
active witness was an active witness and
a passion so I had this odd confidence
of a young young I was 35 when I began
it that it was the only thing that
mattered in my life I didn't have a lot
of money the advance for it was forty
five thousand which you should take off
the agents Commission's forty one
thousand and um er ties that over three
or four years what were called copy boys
now there I think in news clerks at the
New York Times would make more than that
but that's what I wanted to do for those
four years you knew when that it was
going to be a best-seller well we didn't
know there's a wonderful story of my
friends of Richard and Shirley Corman
who were wonderful journalists and they
were at lunch or dinner one day with
Mike Wallace who was at CBS and you know
I disappear when you do a book like this
and my could add they Mike was a friend
of theirs and
what you know what's a David Halberstam
doing and declare instead using a book
on how and why we went to war in Vietnam
and and my life to get a lot of put is
in the amount often I think on other
people's work the way they do it
CBS you know in 60 minutes Mike said
poor David I don't think was ever
thought of as a bet you know bestseller
I thought it was an active witness the
idea that it just exploded
on the bestseller list you know was on
the New York Times list ten book list
thirty six weeks it went to number one
it sold I think two hundred thousand
copies serious book on how and why we
went to war in Vietnam no one thought
that was going to happen I mean if you
get in advance for forty thousand what
they're really thinking is you're going
to sell about twenty thousand copies I
think that's what they bet and it just
took off
have any estimate since it's been
published so many kind of sense and it's
30th anniversary edition I have no
earthly idea man I think we've sold a
couple million copies and different
editions I'm very touched by this new
edition because John McCain has written
a first of it's the you know it's the
modern library which means I sort of
going in the Hall of Fame that you know
it's you know on only kind of people
like bill Styron I mean the big guys go
in there and so I mean I made the cut
but John McCain wrote the introduction
and that's very moving to me because as
we were talking a moment earlier to have
to have been attacked so viciously by
the Pentagon and by the White House and
by all sorts of people in the
conservative press when you're young for
being unpatriotic even as you think
you're doing something rather patriotic
which is writing honestly about a losing
proposition to have it swing full circle
and have someone I esteem like John
McCain I think a legitimate American
hero and an extraordinary man to rise to
have him write the introductions really
wonderful miss it really I wrote him a
note when he said he would do it and in
cut the end and I got the interview I
said you in effect you've made me whole
five minutes until your telephone calls
and questions for David Halberstam we
encourage you to begin dialing now so
you have a chance to talk with him and
ask about the kinds of things
that you've been enriched to seeing in
this reading over the years what do you
think it is about this book the best and
the brightest that has had so much
resonance well are you thinking first if
it was the first community revisionist
book that is up till then all the books
on Kennedy had been written by in effect
what were people in his employ and they
were very articulate and verbal and
there was a sort of romance because of
the terrible way he was murdered there
was a romanticism I mean this was the
greatest administration ever and each
guy was brighter than the other and it
was a Camelot theory and John Kennedy
was you know very talented young
American politician but he was a working
politician and there were there were
some warts there is laws and so I was
the first person who came through and
pushed aside all the mythology on I
think that secondly I think it is a
really good portrait of how politics
works of who that people were who got
power not election elective power but
pry invisible power the people in the in
the core part of the machinery of
national politics I think it's the
portraits I think of for instance of
McNamara the technological whiz kids who
really is a very I think a limited human
being I mean the portrait of Bundy the
portrait of the civilian-military I
think that stuff's very strong it stands
up here year after year more and more
documents have been released and they
all validate the end of the reporting I
really you know I got all the stuff very
very accurately and it's really a very
good book about a country crossing the
Rubicon doesn't terribly ill-prepared
making all the wrong decisions in all
the wrong way and I am there just pure
raw energy I've caught it I think it's a
book that oddly enough has as much and
more validity now than ever John McCain
senator McCain's conclusion and what she
writes in the foreword is I very much
doubt that Americans will ever again
believe that our country has a native
governing class
well that's one of the things that that
book talked about because there was a
kind of elite and there were many good
things about the leaf the elite but in
that particular moment it served us very
badly and there was an arrogance a lack
of listening to people they should have
listened to and and we got we got a lot
of stuff wrong is is he right so what do
we no longer you said it we don't want
we don't have an American establishment
anymore it's it's gone I mean I think
the country's so big it's so
meritocratic it's so diverse there is
there's no elite you could I mean it's
not like I mean in the old days they all
came from this extraordinary school
Groton and you went to Groton anyone it
became Secretary of State I mean it's
changed so much that the only connection
Groton has is that the ex-wife of Groton
graduate Madeleine Albright was
Secretary of State if you'll indulge me
and this is a bit of text that displays
that kennedy revisionism you talked
about I'd like to have you read a little
bit of it sure [ __ ] nice I picked it
up right here this paragraph on the Bay
of Pigs
it's here this is this is where did it
begins where it says it's the best thing
if anything if anything but they have
pigs had made the Kennedy administration
acutely aware of its vulnerability and
determined to show that it was worthy
that this was not a weak young president
unable to cope with the Soviets but that
he was just as tough as they were just
as fast on the draw in the
administration those who are the tough
minded realists were strengthened those
less inclined to use force were weakened
Kennedy would soon have a chance to show
whether he was worthy of his mandate as
the upcoming conference with Nikita
Khrushchev in Vienna in early June a
meeting scheduled so soon after the Bay
of Pigs that the very holding of it was
dubious but he went through with it and
the outcome rather than lowering
tensions increase them the president
left Khrushchev in Vienna feeling had
been bullied more determined than ever
to show Christa that despite his youth
despite the Bay of Pigs he was someone
to connect on jure with he would call up
the reserves and flex American muscle in
many
and of course one of the places was in
Vietnam and there what you illustrate is
something that you talk about in many of
your books but the idea that foreign
policy doesn't involve domestic politics
is well that's one of the great
illusions you know that was one of the
things I was really attacking in those
days there was this illusion politics
Tufts at the water's edge and that
wasn't true I mean our foreign policy
was profoundly affected by domestic
politics by the McCarthy era by the fact
that in did the Democrats I mean John
Lyndon Johnson when he made his
decisions on Vietnam was absolutely
obsessed by the McCarthy period he would
go around saying that when you know
Truman in Atchison lost China they lost
the Congress and therefore he and
therefore he was not going to be the
president of the United States who lost
Vietnam because he would lose the Great
Society he was terribly fearful of being
accused of being weak on communism
because he had seen what the McCarthy
period had done to Truman in Atchison
take our first viewer question Tory it's
from Bogota New Jersey you're on for
David Halberstam
hi good afternoon mr. Adelson I was
wondering why as a nation right now that
we cannot read more of the Arabic legal
aliens that are in this country at the
moment is it I have a couple questions
but this is first is it due to is it
politically incorrect do they help too
much with our economic workforce today
bring a you know they help the economy
because we keep having these threats and
we're going to be more vigilant and have
more security yet the people that are
within the borders for the most part
unfortunately I are you know that are
causing these cutters threat to advocate
we get rid of all their a lot of loyal
the systems of Muslim origin and
our backgrounds and we once before in
our nation's history in December 41 and
early 42 rounded up all kinds of people
Japanese you say Japanese who are
American citizens and put them in and
effect the camps are you whether you
want to call them concentration camps I
don't think they were but they were
detention centers and I think it's a
blot on our history and I think we're
trying in a free society where we are
trust the loyalty of our fellow citizens
to be better this time and we want to be
able and I think it's a real test of a
free society to separate those citizens
our backgrounds who are loyal and love
this country from those who may be a
threat it's difficult it's going to take
time I think we can do this I think
we've been very slow and we've obviously
got to have more people in the security
and intelligence services with Arabic
backgrounds I mean who speak the
languages and work over there here I
mean to work here but I mean just
rounding up people as you seem to
suggest I think that that would be a
great victory for our opponents our
adversaries they would make us fear each
other and we don't want that to this
point in your writing career at least in
book form you have not dug into the
American politics of the Middle East no
I haven't and that's probably because
I'm Jewish when I joined the New York
Times they didn't send reporters who
were Jewish to the to the Middle East it
was a sword there was and that's changed
I think Tom Friedman is a good example
of that but in those days there was sort
of it was off limits I think they
thought you were going to be under too
much pressure and as such I didn't have
it early on in my curriculum vitae
probably in addition there's always the
feeling that you know if you're Jewish
and you're right about the Middle East
you're going to get attacked so much
from either side you know you're either
going to be called someone who's toting
to the Israelis or as often happens a
self-hating Jew if you're in some way
critical so I thought well there enough
really good people qualified people who
do that and I think Tom Friedman is
really so so gifted and they're a lot of
other people that I was free to do other
things so I've never been drawn to a
come in part I think because I didn't
work there when I was young
Hammond Indiana yes you're on the air is
this
about some boxes blow me you have a
question for David Halberstam well I was
watching c-span here okay
Thank You Cole we're going to move on to
Chicago and you're on for David
Halberstam
I'd like to ask whether he whether mr.
Halberstam sees any parallels between
the decision-making processes that led
to Vietnam and the decision-making
processes that are going on now with
respect to containing terrorism well I
think they're very different I mean I
think you're talking apples and oranges
I think Vietnam was a historic
miscalculation the wrong war the wrong
time the wrong place where we misread
history I mean one of the things I
really remember is the patch that all
American troops wore when they went
there and was a sword piercing the wall
of China that was in which we were there
to pierce the ball of China as if we
were fighting communist China but of
course a Vietnamese nationalism which is
what we run ran into there and why we
didn't win the war in the Ho Chi Minh
and then van dong and Bowen Japs leaders
at the side had much greater title to
nationalism because they'd kicked the
French out then our Vietnamese the arvin
and the government in the south but
Vietnamese nationalism is historically
opposed to China so we really completely
misread that and we went rather
gratuitously
into an unwinnable war this is something
very different because this is a war
that has come to find us these people
have an effect declared war on us and
now we are trying to figure out and it's
hard to do it under pressure and we
everybody expect the processes to work
very well we're trying to figure I think
that this is a pretty competent
administration struggling under you know
difficult circumstances going from a
time of peace into a time of war to do
the right thing I don't see many
parallels yet I don't see any hubris
here
Las Vegas you're on for David Halberstam
hi Susan and hi mr. Halberstam honey mr.
halberstam I'm a great admirer of yours
and I do
I've read about half your books and so I
have three questions for you
number one do you have a favorite of
your seventeen books number two apart
from the best and the brightest of which
of your books do you think is have the
greatest effect and third since you're a
baseball fan and you've written about
baseball may we have your prediction on
tonight's STI the World Series thank you
very much I mean if I can and well you
know when you ask someone else which of
your books or your baby is your favorite
it's sort of like you ask someone of the
large family which of your children do
you like best but there are two books
that that probably aren't as well known
that I'm particularly I mean as a small
book I did on rowing called the amateurs
for single scull rowers rowing fanned
that my wife thinks is in a way the best
book I've ever done I mean it's whatever
it is I just nailed it in God and it's a
wonderful look at a an old-fashioned
sport with old-fashioned values sort of
a hermetically sealed world and I really
am very fond to that book and then
there's a book I did called the children
about the civil rights kids the early
first really civil rights students there
in Nashville Tennessee who became the
leaders of snick and challenged the the
the archaic racist laws of our country
and I think that I'm terribly moved by
their courage their loyalty their faith
and I that is a favorite book as well I
mean because it's a book about about
courage and about really about faith and
I didn't think of myself writing a book
about faith but they really it's it's
very moving moving their heroism
among those profiled are to who went on
to careers in politics yeah well one was
great distinction and one with marginal
distinction negative distinction Jean
Louis was probably was a congressman
from Georgia who I met in 1960 when he
was probably about 18 years old and I
think is the best American citizen I've
ever met I mean just I think of John and
I think of the West Point motto duty
honor country and then Marion Barry who
later became mayor of Washington and I
think and was this very sweet young man
when I first met him and then
became upon election here I think almost
symbolically corrupt in terms of his
personal behavior and really was a
cataclysmic figure I think for the city
what are the lessons about American
society one can draw from the children
that it is an open society that we can
change that we really can here the
smaller voices in our society when these
young people start out up on a started
out to challenge the laws in Nashville
on February 1960 that didn't allow them
to have a world worst hamburger they
take a job at Woolworth could not eat a
hamburger right there at their little
cafeteria there um and nobody was on
their side the federal government the
local government to state governments I
mean nobody is and they starting there
and gradually getting victories and then
going on the Freedom Rides and then
challenging voting rights that excluded
blacks from voting I mean they gradually
turn the entire country around in a
period of five or six years so I mean I
think you there it's a room it's a
reminder that you can bring change and
that the powerless can assault the
powerful and if they're if they have
right on their side occasionally they
can win you just described it as a story
of safe I thought I read in your
author's notes which you so frequently
do that it was actually at the time of
story about religion well I think so I
mean I think that they would I mean
their faith is a religious faith I mean
they are they were young the Protestant
Southern Baptists mostly and there's I
mean John I once asked John who is how
they could do it and you know the Tovar
I mean there they were without weapons
taking on the Ku Klux Klan the power of
the government in Alabama and
Mississippi the you know the power of
the state police the local police I mean
really tough tough people wanted to kill
it in John said well in a faith in each
other faith in Jim Lawson identity as
minister taught them self a faith in our
God faith that we would not let each
other down and then he had it various
with faith in America which up till then
had done so little for our family it
really is religious faith in America in
2001 is religion that a strong effect or
could it be in our society in our
current situation what I think it is for
some people I think it varies I think
some you know people take great
sustenance from and I think it's
important at a moment like this I think
when the things that you have killed it
on to work the strength and security of
a society the material success of the
slightest decision phenomenally
successfully successful material in the
last forty or fifty years in particular
in last ten or twelve I mean it's just
been the stunning me and the Clinton
years the the Dow went up six thousand
points more than doubled when those
things are pulled off the table suddenly
you're not as secure as you thought
suddenly the economy seems softer then
you have to find reassurance and
confidence in things that you perhaps
didn't think we're so important
previously and I think a lot of people
will take sustenance from their religion
or there are other forms of faith I mean
I think there's secular faith out there
I have a kind of secular faith in in the
process use of this country that we will
by and large do the right thing on any
major event when we put our attention to
it our next question for you comes from
God by the way I didn't answer the guy's
question all about the web there is the
reason I think it's a great World Series
I always thought it would go seven games
and I think it's a column I mean if you
got chilling on three days rest versus
Clemens and a little bit more arrests
but shillings and pitching better this
year
then then Clemens it's really about it's
a column game and so it's been a great
world series I mean twice them two out
in the ninth inning 27th out and the
Yankees have had home runs so I mean I
don't know what more I think it's a
success either way if you're if you're
in New York fan wedding most three games
in New York against those odds and two
in the lab in the ninth-inning I mean
with the homeruns I mean it's just been
a wonderful thing next question for you
comes from Springfield Missouri you're
on the air
yes I want to do ask mr. Alveston on he
is so successful at doing what I call
small profiles of people within books
such as McGeorge Bundy or Robert
McNamara in the best and the brightest
or the Chandler family and his book on
media does he separate out the profiles
or know that he's going to have to do
certain profiles and separate those out
in his research and do those kind of
separate and Phil omean or does that
just come naturally with the research
that he does on the book well it's a
dream it's a very good question and it's
a little bit of both when you do a book
the best in the brightest or more
recently war in the time of peace you're
you're trying to get a narrative you
start with a detective nights really
begins as as the Royal what I try to do
and I really learned from Theodore white
Teddy White who did the making of
president 1960 but that if you're going
to be a nonfiction writer and you want
to try and sell some books or make your
books valuable and accessible but you
have to be good storyteller I mean it
you don't want to write a book that's
accurate and everybody learn you say oh
this is a very good accurate book and
it's a book all Americans should read in
it sits there unopened on a coffee table
you really don't want that you want to
bring people in so what was interesting
when Teddy why did the making of a
president 1960 everybody knew the
outcome you know that John Kennedy had
beaten Richard Nixon on people that
Teddy what are you doing that for when
he was out you know what he was on the
campaign's what are you doing writing a
book about the campaign so everybody's
going to know the answer but he made it
a cliffhanger me read that book you
couldn't wait to see who's going to win
well I try to do the same thing with the
best advice everybody knew that we had
crossed the Rubicon and gone into
Vietnam but the question of why so it
was it
effective novel who did and why now when
you do that or even when you do war in a
time of peace you have a given you have
a question the country makes a key
decision and hinges so you're doing the
decision-making the era the forces that
play the politics but the people so
you're doing the narrative doesn't run
you know what are the issues what are
some of the other things that factor in
the politic but you're also always doing
the people so when you're interviewing
you're interviewing trouble some people
you interview exclusively for
biographical stuff X or Y you know the
only thing they don't know anything else
but they know one of the players but a
lot of times you're doing both you're
getting a narrative why they do
something that why a decision was made
what the meeting was like but they just
saying well what was a Toni Lake like or
what was McGeorge Bundy like or what was
dick Holbrooke like I mean you're trying
to get by growl so you're really working
at two levels and then in the old days
when you know you type up your notes now
I have someone who helps me with it i
dictate notes and you cut out the
biographical stuff and you put the stuff
on on say on Kosovo or biographical
stuff into one pile and another so that
a year you know as you're writing your
book you'll go from it a narration about
how a decision was made in the forces
and then you'll go to a biographical
sketch and then you'll go back to
narration you're trying to learn and
improve your storytelling ability all
the time because you want people to
start the book and finished about over
the course of 30 plus years of
interviewing first-person actors in many
of the world's great events as we've
seen that those interviews above and
beyond the books you produce but have
value are you preserving your archives
all what I do I interview now that's
when I did the best in the brightest and
we as we have discussed earlier is broke
I just broke all that I mean that was a
very hard time because I was doing that
book and you know I did a little bit of
writing on the side did some lecturing
but ten thousand year even in early
nineteen seventy dollars wasn't it
wasn't a lot of money I typed my notes
myself now
when that book did well the one luxury
was I would interview someone writing
along in it
I'd say you know you're going too fast
slow down and I'd write it down and
write it down I'd go home and I would
dictate my notes into a cassette and
then I gave them to a typist usually
retired got a wonderful woman in Carolyn
Park with who types up for me now and
she types them and then I keep the OEE
and I have two sets and now when and
then when the when the nodes when the
book is done I send all my papers at
Boston University and they've got there
which is great if you're in a New York
apartment because you'd be up to here
and paper my wife is so grateful Jean
Halberstam is so grateful to Boston
University for getting all that paper
out of our apartment wonderful man named
there named Howard godly boost sort of
watches over me my papers have been
there for 37 years and my notes go there
and there's a lovely guy named Tom
Griffith who was a top editor time-life
and he did a book once on Teddy white
and Harry Lucy and he went up anything
could you look at my notes and I said
sure any one of them came back he said
most of the greatest notes I've ever
seen I mean they're all so careful
they're so well they should I had to
look at Teddy White's notes and it was
like you know was chicken scratches in a
pad they are very good notes why Boston
well in 1964 when I came back from
Vietnam and I was a 29 years old I got
to be 30
Howard Gottlieb said he would like my
papers and I thought he was kidding and
he said no he was dead serious so I said
sure and I had all my stuff all my notes
and soon as I gave them to him and it's
I mean he was the first there and he's
been terrific it's accessible they do a
wonderful job he is a great librarian
he's a wonderful charming man a great
boulevardier Howard Howard godly biz and
it has been one of the boons of our
lives we are not overwhelmed by paper in
our apartment you can reach David
Halberstam in an other way besides
telephone calls will also take email
questions for him the address is book TV
at c-span org a next phone call comes
from Utica New York Utica you are on the
air welcome yes good morning mr. Howell
Stern
and I'm not again at all of these
programs my only attempt to prior to
this was when mr. Brookhiser resigned
and then the program was interrupted for
the reaction beginning to take place
Afghanistan but the question I was going
to post and prior to the question I'd
like to pose to you I just wonder what
your response might face his book had to
do with George Washington and he was
great lover Furyk and came from
Rochester and you were resident New York
so so many times in our country we put
up butyl edifices
and we put these wonderful sayings on
them and are they only to decorate the
edifice or to people take them to heart
so I'm curious as to whether or not
you're familiar with the quote from
George Washington I'm in Washington
Memorial and at the Boston Park in
Washington partner like the window
what's the quote collar piece lettuce
raise the standard to which the good -
nay repair the matter is in the hands of
God and you think that quote has
particular poignancy now call it I think
it is particular poignancy college
so listen what's your to help us and
thoughts on that thing well I mean I'm a
George Washington fan I mean I think
it's amazing the more you put you know
when you're young you learn that he's
their father of you kind of the father
of your country and then you sort of go
away from early American history and you
begin to think well probably there's a
lot of spin and maybe wasn't that
extremely and then you go back as a
grown man and started reading about him
and you come away with a sense of
extraordinary qualities of courage and
sudden the ability to sustain an ideal
in a difficult time and I mean strengths
all kinds of other people were really
letting him down the qualities was in
were uncommon so I don't think it's a
bad quote I think it's pretty good I
must say the data
the bombing started when we started
bombing the quote that jumped into my
mind was from Emerson events are in the
saddle and ride mankind I mean meaning
that we unpowered forces had been
uncapped in both sides and would not
lightly be kept again that something
very big tough and fierce was now at
play and could not lightly be stopped
you know I have found that quote in a
number of your book as you will find
that quote in it was used by George ball
in in 1964 on his papers because he
thought that they kept thinking he was a
pall because they kept thinking they had
options and he was telling them in fact
every day that they didn't stop this
they had fewer options but it's a very
very good quote next call for use from
Boston welcome to the program
oh yes hello I just have a call for I
mean ask question from Sahab I said I'm
sorry I'm nervous it's just you the two
of us in I just like you to comment on
some of the attacks that the press of
certain reporters have gotten when
they've turned in ask the question in
regards to September 11th what our
government what what they had been up to
or what their foreign policy was or they
just asked the question why did these
terrorists fly an airplane into the
World Trade Center I just like to hear
your comments on I know that on there
have been some reporters and writers who
have been censored by their editors or
in some cases fired because of asking
that question the turning to our
governments and hey what's what's going
on here and why are people attacking us
I know that when I was in the military I
was stationed aboard an aircraft carrier
and we shot down two aircraft over Libya
and when I read in a LA Times
and when I witnessed went to different
things so I just wonder if you if we're
getting on the reporting and is
accurately as as it should be because I
feel like maybe some of the reporters
are afraid to write or ask these
important questions out of three of the
their job or mom gift and II thought
well I I haven't heard of anybody being
fired and I must say I'm heard of any
reporters being in on effect of of
threatened by their bosses for being too
critical I think we are entering a very
tense time in relationship between
government and press I mean I think it's
always difficult when there is one
awards on him I mean Vietnam is a very
good example of the fact that it didn't
work in the government was saying that
it did work and the reporters were early
on the early dissenters in sense of
saying giving pessimistic appraisals and
we took in that rather innocent Eretz
and much more innocent than that now we
took a lot of heat for being pessimistic
early on I've talked a little bit about
this already this one's going to be much
harder because it's an invisible enemy
he uses the enemy uses stealth false
identity identity diseases he lives
among us and wants to blow us up so you
can't fight him in a normal wartime
situation so it brings out I mean
therefore you fight him in a certain way
and it doesn't lend itself to an open
society so the government has some
legitimate views about control of
information and of course the press
wants to cover at the same time it
doesn't want to be isolated as looking
unpatriotic so every there's all kinds
of political stuff that is at play here
I think it's a very important time for
both sides for the government and the
press to be wise to understand that it's
a new kind of equation I think it's very
important for the government you know
one of the great be one of the few
growth industries in our country in the
last 20 years has been
all kinds of people now know how to
spend the most because the media's
become so important the most important
thing at the end of the day was to get
your vision out on television didn't
mean mine even matter if what you were
saying was accurate or true whatever as
long as you got it out I mean spinning
something giving your side of an event
in your your rationale for something was
more important this seems to me a very
good time for everybody not to spin to
sort of try and understand that if we go
into a very difficult confrontation like
this where so little traditional
reporting can be done that hour but the
credibility of our government when we
say something it better be accurate
because if it's shown that we're not
telling the truth to the people and
they're dependent on the truth and then
later turns out it's not true the
credibility of the government will begin
dropping people will not trust again
it's very important but the government's
word seems to mean in this moment could
be unusually sacred and they ought to be
very respectful of what they do because
we don't have very easy access to
alternative versions in most cases the
government says one thing if you're a
journalist you can go and talk to other
people you can do a balance now the
government itself has to be aware that
it is really on the spot and to be very
careful with its use of its credibility
on the journalistic side we've seen a
lot of discussions on the 24-hour news
channels of public soul-searching for
reporters about the equation of being
patriotic and objective and reporting at
the same time what are you thoughts on
that well I think that 24-hour news
cycles could all do with instead of
worrying so much about patriotism and
objectivity which I don't think they've
ever I don't think of the big stars of
the 24-hour news cycle is being terribly
worried about objectivity I see Muslim
worried about some promotion I I think
they ought to worry more about being
intelligent I think they would be more
thinking more about putting on people
know something and not I think one of
the things that's really a problem in
this society is the 24-hour news cycle I
think it's a giant monster that needs to
eat and
eat and eat and chew on stuff in it and
so there has to be information even when
and there has to be an event or pseudo
event when there's not one I mean it's
the toilets that it's the the 24-hour
news cycles of called those people
who've given us no small part of the
tabloid agenda that we've had for the
last dozen or so years and they're the
people who were staking out Gary
Congress and Gary Condit house and the
levee house they're the ones who feasted
on the Lewinsky thing and made it so
much bigger than it really was I mean
you know drove this thing because it was
something they could get their hands on
and they've really given our agenda
trivialization so I'm I'm not terribly
worried about their new soul searching
about their patriotism i I'd really like
to see them more thoughtful I think that
we haven't learned I mean the hunger of
the oven of the news cycles there and
the need to kind of drive something and
to seize on stories that really would
have been smaller stories in another era
but our big stories like the Condit
story or that's an interesting story but
it wasn't the preeminent story of the of
several months the way they drove it but
they liked that kind of tabloid
sensationalist ourian we're spending
three hours of david halberstam talking
about his writing career this is he
spent oozed in-depth series next call
for him is from San Francisco you're on
the air mr. hammer stamp I'm curious
about the habit of your writing for
example when you do it
what are these surroundings that allow
you focus and inspiration and how does
your have it differ from being in New
York in the winter versus Nantucket good
question well when I first started
writing a full-time on books in which
was 1969 I had bought a house in
Nantucket which you could then do even
if you were still a journalist it wasn't
yet the quite the playground of the.com
rich or the Wall Street rich that it is
since become and I did most of my
writing there this is pre a computer pre
personal computer days and I would try
and do my interviewing in the what we
call the mainland in the United States
and then by the time so if I got there
in June and I would really just be able
to sit there for three or four months
writing everyday and then come off and
the big great thing because I'd write
for a couple four or five hours in the
morning and maybe go fishing in the
afternoon something like that and so
when I left the island after three or
four months I have a huge chunk of a
book done and yet I feel like I'd had a
vacation and then in time my wife and I
had a daughter in our schedules change
the new tyranny of children schools
appeared we we turned out we had an
air-conditioned our apartment we just
when we built it we had nothing of a cuz
we were it was hot we were in [ __ ] it we
had to redo our apartment and put in
central air conditioning and and and you
begin to adapt your writing schedule
more mortar was in New York and and it
was adapted to to family needs but the
key and in the key thing though is is a
schedule being sort of brutal about in
Nantucket was easier because there are
fewer distractions and you're sort of
fewer pressures on you but in New York I
would get up usually around you might
get up now we have dogs and four time
one before our daughter went off you
know have breakfast with her and then I
would try and be writing by about nine
o'clock and I would try and write for
four or five hours and that's a long day
and then I would be and then take the
rest of the day off you just were
rolling some pictures of you at work in
your office and it looks a little filled
with paper yeah it's an somebody I would
I once worked next to has on New York
Times a wonderful and that's the Robert
Kennedy award for book I got that for
the children with John Lewis and I think
both won that year that's some books in
the back there I think there's my friend
Michael Arlen's book
American verdict this is that your own
system for organizing on yeah it's this
this organization is is triumphant in my
in my house up
i sat next to CP true cell when I was
briefly on the New York Times and in
1961 Petrus L was an old-timer and he
been with Truman the day Truman the day
Roosevelt died and he wants much to
music you're a one-man swamp I mean yes
lovely but I mean I'm I'm a great
accumulator of paper that just does of
the bookshelves on the left are all my
own books and then at the top are losing
there's a Nantucket stuff ship there
that's the Harvard Crimson mom that you
get with your name on it so that's at
least 50 years old
yeah next call for use from Fairbanks
Alaska it well thank you very much for
this c-span is just fantastic my
question to David is in the situation we
have in Afghanistan today can can you
say any other alternative we would have
rather than bombing these people I guess
I'm kind of concerned that we are going
to kill a lot of people there and I mean
some of you want to kill probably but I
mean it'd be like children kids little
you know people that are going to die
either through the starvation and they
come up and relax food can you see any
alternative I don't I I mean I you know
that as I say the day the bombing began
I had a melancholy feeling of and I use
that phrase of from Emerson events are
in the saddle and ride mankind and I you
sat there thinking you know I what
alternatives are there and I didn't
think so I think it's hard I don't think
the Taliban is particularly vulnerable
to traditional weaponry that we have I
think we have to do it I think we have
to
set them back I don't have great faith
in the military abilities of the
Northern Alliance I perhaps they'll do
better and I think bombing is a somewhat
crude instrument in a situation like
that and that they are because of the
way the Taliban function in caves and
probably moving among the population in
some of the cities and moving into
mosques and moving into hospitals and
things like that it's going to be
extremely hard I have no illusion that
is easy I have no illusion that you in
doing this may end up doing some of
their recruiting for them even as you
are momentarily military successful if
you know something about Vietnam you
knew that sometimes your military
successes also work for the other side
and it allowed them to do their
recruiting but I don't see much
alternative to this your latest before
in a time of peace is really a study of
the success of tactical air strikes in
it worked very well in Serbia I mean the
new high precision of bombing is really
pretty brilliant and if there is a
traditional target and the Serbs in the
cost of home campaign did give us a
number of targets and we I mean we were
able to take out bridges and we did
things and people didn't think could be
done by bombing in fact it was the most
I mean people like myself who had always
been skeptical about what airpower could
do alone I mean Vietnam certainly would
make you that I mean I always understood
that airpower could be very well be
effective in a tactical sense and that
is if you are fighting an enemy and you
have air power over the battlefield
shooting at their tanks or whatever it
done that's attack air and that that's a
great asset but in strategic air both in
Korea and in Vietnam there were great
limits to it because the the terrain and
the enemy the enemy was such that he was
able to either work at night or any
thick foliage used tunnels in Vietnam so
the strategic bombing never was as
effective as it has as it's a fan's
proclaimed
what's really true is I mean people like
me who had doubts about air power we're
really wrong I mean just to be blunt I
was wrong about the effectiveness of air
power in Co so it was much more
effective than I would have thought I
asked a quick story before their next
call it was struck reading about someone
you call Matt or is nicknamed by
colleagues Matt John Wardle he's the
architect of this new modern campaign
and it demonstrates sometimes that small
circumstances can have big consequences
you write that he normally wouldn't have
been given the job of creating the
campaign but his superior who was more
conventional was on Lee was on leave and
they didn't like him he was really sort
of a renegade maverick and he had the
idea that you could you take modern air
power that it was so accurate and
precise would be like taking and
particularly obviously the more
developed the society the more effective
it is I don't think it's very defective
against the Taliban and in Afghanistan
but it would be effective against Serbia
Anton and to Iraq that instead of
getting into a really conventional
traditional war you could use the
bombing almost like taking a hypodermic
needle and freezing the the nervous
system of an enemy you could take out
the communications take out the military
communications you could really freeze
the system and isolate its forces in the
field and we did precisely that in in
the Gulf War I mean so that by the time
the ground war started it was a defeated
army really I think and and it was John
worden who was the architect of this and
I think it's quite a brilliant it's
really something well worth reading
about because I spent a lot of time on
it because I was so surprised by the
accuracy of what he came up with next
question for you comes from Little Falls
New York yes first of all I'd like to
thank mr. garvik's John for most of his
books that I have read and I would also
like to suggest some new ones
number one no journalist has written yet
that Ronald Reagan's
use of the word liberal in such a
pejorative way that today you almost
have to prove you are patriotic if you
say you are liberal it's
sounds like they're saying communist and
the effect that this is had on free
speech and the kind of colonists that
are allowed and the kind of talk shows
that we have this needs to be written
because it has done more damage than
McCarthyism did number two and we need a
look powers that be to at the control of
the media by the conservatives it is
even worse than what I read in your book
at the time number three the election
results as a patriotic American I was
more depressed by what happened in
Florida than I was by the Kennedy
assassination
that was serendipity this went to the
heart of our democratic system I'm a
college professor and I teach that bolts
overcome money don't overcome power and
they didn't and the last one why have we
not heard that a consortium of
newspapers that the University of
Chicago to do a research study that this
study was supposed to be released
September 17th and they are holding it
back for supposedly patriotic reasons or
it might cause too much difficulty for
the country thank you that's a lot work
with this select one is on the election
outcome I just I in fact I heard is in
fact that the consortium had more or
less shown that a bush won but I'm not
really aware of it a Jeffrey Toobin by
the way is a very talented young writer
has written has just written a book on
the Florida election I presume it is
he's done awfully good work in the past
I presume he's done it with his usual
excellence I mean there's no doubt two
things one there's no doubt that the
surge of the Reagan years and the
conservative movement
in the country did seem to make the word
liberal seem pejorative I think that
that's come back a little bit I think
the pendulum in our politics swings back
and forth and I think the callers
writing in one sense I mean that the you
were doing the powers-that-be that which
I did in came out 22 years ago is a very
would be a very different book because
the power is very fragmented but there's
no doubt that the power in the media and
the coming of large corporations I don't
think that there's so much concern I
don't think if it's a liberal
conservative struggle but I think it is
a trivial serious struggle I think the
networks have become infinitely more
trivial in the ensuing 20 years it is
really because the proprietorial
generation that I wrote about in the
networks people I mean whatever their
flaws and they were not inconsiderable
Paley and Sarnoff have been replaced by
people that are giant corporations the
only thing they care about is the stock
they look at the bottom line and they
find it Oh foreign correspondents well
that's expensive and we don't get much
out of them and no one cares about
foreign policy the ratings are down but
Oh a good trivial report about a
Hollywood celebrity well that's terrific
it's not expensive and so what you've
gotten is I think a decreasing quality
of serious journalism out of the
network's I mean real scandalizing
because they've gotten rid of all their
foreign correspondents and they started
rewarding what I would call the feather
mergency the male and female divas of
artificial empathy who can who have
access to Hollywood celebrities and you
know people in the Condit case or the
Lewinsky case that's become the big
thing and it's because it drives the
rating is not liberal conservative it
makes money and so we have as a kind of
journalism you start out in it it's not
good journalism but it's good for the
ratings which is good for the stock and
I think bad for the countries one of the
reasons why we were partially asleep on
September 11th we'd we'd binge Daz a
country not looking in terms of being
self-absorbed and not paying attention
to the rest of the world it criticized
the network's did the same sort of thing
happen to major newspapers with militia
certainly not the Washington Post and
The New York Times or The Wall Street
Journal's news branch LA Times was I
think in trouble because you had a
managerial generation although it's
getting better again and all kinds of
papers across the country are not nearly
as good as they used to be because
they're owned by large companies
corporations knight-ridder has gotten
much much worse than it used to be the
level of journalism's gone down because
they're trying to drive a Tony Ritter
they're trying to drive the stock up and
the norms of the stock are diminishing
the quality of the journalism Manhattan
is our next caller for you welcome yeah
hello this is a question for David our
time my name is gravy what Long's
Oh mr. Hollis time as I saw mr. Acme's
Holmstrom David as the European living
in Manhattan one of the things that
shocks me most was the perception of the
president when older then saying that he
was really
Sonne about shocked about the reaction
that abroad they had towards America and
the hatred of America and and this lack
of perception of having being travel
around the world it's really concerning
those if the president really was
discovering his new this new face of a
relative at me traveling abroad I have
felt for so long and my American friends
traveling - how can you address his lack
of historical knowledge or I think it's
a been an insular time in America and
the President himself was er when he ran
and was elected he said not anymore
maybe but he was a reflection of that
insularity he had never traveled he'd
been to Mexico and I guess he'd visit
his father in China and his father was
the the country had turned inward I
think it goes back to the end of the
Cold War I mean I think we've always
been essentially isolationist
I think to understand America you have
to understand our geography the the
impact of the two oceans and the sense
that we are separated from the rest of
the world and we quite like it that way
by the way and then that changed at the
end of World War two for a variety of
reasons one the generation that had
fought the war had paid and seen the
price paid for the calamitous quality of
the isolationism
in addition they'd lost their friends
their college roommates and in addition
the weaponry had changed at the end of
the war we'd come up with the atomic
bomb and Germans had come up with
rockets and that was obviously and the
oceans became pawns but when as the Cold
War began to wind down as the as the
threat from the Soviet Union began to
diminish and ended in the Soviet Union
collapsed the the oceans became ponds
again and then palms be the pawns became
oceans we felt more protected again we
felt invulnerable world and we binge Don
self-absorption so we didn't know what
the rest of the world felt and we had to
understand that if you are a monopoly
superpower if the Russians are no longer
a threat that that the rest of the world
now has an excuse to not like you that
nobody roots for Goliath will chamber
when we will change when a basketball
player was seven feet tall everybody
wherever he went except at his home
court everybody booed him because as he
said no one roots for Goliath we've
gotten a number of interesting questions
by email I'm going to try to work those
European calls here's one from Bonnie
Lincoln watching us in Fort Myers
Florida who writes when Robert McNamara
revealed recently he had known the
Vietnam War was unwinnable but pursued
it anyway this seemed to provoke two
basic reactions relief in gratification
that he finally told the truth and in
effect vindicated the anti-war movement
an outrage that he had continued to
sacrifice lives to the lost cause what
was your take I think the latter feeling
in general is much more powerful I don't
think there was much relief that this
man who
had been such a forceful player and had
remained silent for so long and
everybody knew he had had doubts but
he'd been so deeply disingenuous for
more than 30 years I think the rage on
the part of most people that he now is
coming to the table with this very badly
done both very dishonest book that he
wrote of that I think there was mostly
raged I didn't see much relief I think
there was a real ray it was like tearing
opens car that had finally begun to heal
you almost tear it open again the book
was so dishonest because he says you
know finally first assignment for 30
years which is unacceptable me was a
player he owed us and his crimes there
were never war crimes I don't believe in
war crime forehand Bundy the crime of
silence while this debate was taking
place here's a man who by February 1966
believed the war was unwinnable and
remained silent I mean I think that is
truly shocking in a free society but one
of the things she says in there there's
a sentence I forgot I used to know what
page it was on page 39 is not just
waiting
none of us Mac Bundy Dean rust the
president me Maxwell Taylor could ever
get the information we wanted I thought
I rather than I thought you son of a
[ __ ] you will just still lying because
he was more than anyone else the person
who beheaded the messengers who brought
them bad news I mean I saw it I
witnessed it I was a victim of it myself
it started as early as 1962 when a
Desmond Fitzgerald who is the father of
Frances Fitzgerald the writer Desmond
Fitzgerald I think was the number three
person in the CIA who went and briefed
in once a week and Desmond Desmond
Fitzgerald goes over to debrief him and
McEnroe's asking commented quantified
how many of there's how many about how
many on the event and finally does mr.
Stilson mr. Secker day I don't think
these numbers mean much you know I don't
think so and I mean well I just think I
have a bad feeling about that doesn't
smell right out there every night and
the meeting is almost immediately called
oh I mean terminates the meeting and as
Desmond could show walking across this
large office
McNamara
says to recenter in a very loud voice I
never want that man to brief me again
okay scene two John Van whom both Neil
Sheehan and I wrote about at great
length in its in summer of 63 he's
honest he's come home in fact he and I'm
writing pessimistically there he's
getting pessimistic briefings as ever
higher levels in the Pentagon in fact
they almost court-martial because they
think he's the source of my stories you
know I haven't seen him in a couple of
months he's supposed to into grief the
Joint Chiefs on a given morning and he
shows up and everything starts and hairs
back and he's there with the master
sergeant who's in charge of it the phone
rings the master sergeant picks up the
phone says such a listen Jesus now I get
this right the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs and the Secretary of Defense want
that item stricken from the agenda yes I
want to get it right both yes I mean the
terms advance says looks like you don't
breathe today buddy
it was McNamara and Mac Taylor who
struck out crossed off the dissenting
pessimistic warning third Singh and then
I give you 20 more it's the fall it's
about October 1963 in Vietnam Neil and I
and all the other reporters are clued in
the war is being lost Henry Cabot Lodge
matter is over Henry Cabot Lodge is the
Ambassador he asks us to talk to
McNamara about how the war is going
I don't think reporters should be public
officials but lodge had helped us get
access on helicopters so we agreed to do
it we go into this meeting four or five
of us all go on to win the Pulitzer
Prize by the way McNamara turns and the
rules are suddenly explained we cannot
talk about the military status we can
only talk about the political status
that means he can go back to Washington
and say when he gets home that he didn't
hear anyone say that the war wasn't
going well all the way through in those
years he was cutting off the heads of
anyone
tried to descend so for him to say that
we could never get the information I
think he's the biggest lying son of a
[ __ ] that this country ever produced in
government I hate that book nanny gets
away with it I mean doesn't get read no
he didn't get away with it but he
thought he could get away with next call
for you is Wilsonville Oregon go ahead
mr. halbert's you authored the breaks of
the game in 1981 season with the
Portland Trail Blazers sir I have a
question involving Bill Walton sir did
you have an opportunity to discuss
Waltons foot problems with dr. Bob Cook
his position and if so were you given an
explanation by him on white walton
allowed their close friendship to end in
anger and bitterness over his perception
on the way he was treated well I did
like you know there's a very painful
moment because Bob Cook the doctor and
Bill Walton had been very close friends
bill was a great athlete he had this
extraordinary body and ability but he
had sort of your grandmother's feet and
eventually his feet broke down he did
take a shot the shot turned out to be
catastrophic for him and real bitterness
grew out of that and what had been once
a very good relationship with Bob cook
ended you know I have a question from my
email that would be a nice follow-on to
that one if I can find it real quickly
it's a viewer who writes and this is a
New Yorker who writes why do you have a
serious interest in spectator sports
which I find quite childish please give
us a philosophical response and not the
usual empty sentimentality it's Charles
Thomas of New York well I mean I enjoy
the sport it's a great window on
American society I mean if you want to
know what television has done to our
society how it changes its effect
effect of the money that it brings in
how it changes value systems the changes
in authority I mean for instance sports
where once owners were all powerful now
athletes are all powerful sportswear
managers or coaches once we're all
powerful and where the athletes are all
powerful you know if you want to
understand change levels of authority
and finances you better look first at
sports you can understand it better the
effect of television on on any number of
institutions you can understand it more
readily in sports in addition if you
want to understand race in America you
do well to understand sports it's a
great window on society I mean I did a
book summer of 49 which was on a a
season in a baseball pennant in in 1949
and it was a great window on an America
that no longer existed because in that
day it was total of only 16 teams a
southern team was Washington a Western
team was st. Louis the teams played in
the daytime they traveled by train
the teams were almost entirely white I
mean you know if he made the owners had
all powerful player didn't like this
this contract the owner sent him all he
had to do was retire that was his
alternative he couldn't trade himself he
couldn't hold out I mean so you take
that and you jump ahead to 1989 or the
year 2000 you get a sense of how
dramatically the society has changed so
it's a great great window I enjoy it of
writers unlike academics do not get
sabbaticals I mean we don't get every
seventh year off I mean I have to write
every day I have to do leg work every
day so one of the nice things that
happened it began with the portland book
was in addition to what are allegedly
serious books as I do on politics and
the society I do these sports books
about every third book or so is a book
on sports they're great fun I meet
people that I like it enriches me it
I'm allowed it's a little bit less
pressurized so I enjoyed a sort of a bit
of a sabbatical Graham green used to do
this he'd write these very serious
novels and then he'd write what he
called entertainments which were
detective novels these are my these are
my entertainments and I've enjoyed them
they've been rich to me greatly I've
made some wonderful friends and I've
learned I mean if you want to I've
learned a lot I mean if you wanted to
understand how cable society changed
coming of cable television changed
America I mean doing my Michael Jordan
book was the way to do it I mean the
creation of a celebrity culture begins
with the coming of the cable networks
that book is playing for keeps Michael
Jordan in the world he made next calls
from Oxford Mississippi hey hi dr. must
help stem yeah I have a question about
October 64 you look on baseball did that
book do well and if so are you planning
on doing another one some of that for
later team later season well it did well
the the first book on baseball summer 49
just did phenomenally well and I think
it's it's you know still selling very
well it was number one it was
interesting I did one book on baseball
summer 49 there was a number one
bestsellers in New York Times and then
one book on how I went to war in Vietnam
that was also number one on the New York
Times list so I had these two books that
couldn't be more different that went to
the top of that you know to the
mountaintop and October 64 did well not
white as well but it was a very good
bestseller and it got out there and
people enjoyed reading it I don't know
I'll do more sports books I don't know
if I'll do another baseball book I'm
just not sure at this moment I don't
want to push this too much but as I was
preparing for our conversation it struck
me that that just in the past two weeks
Michael Jordan's back playing baseball
Yankees are in the series you know a
Ford has taken over at Ford Motor Co
knee
the United States is fighting a war
against people with hundreds of years of
history and it's being covered and then
it sensibly but I mean it seems like all
of your subject matter my my friend
Russell Baker was wonderful colleague
and was longtime New York Times reporter
and columnist talking about the new book
Warren timepiece and being very generous
about it said that he thought it caught
the arc of my career that all the other
things that I've been doing in these
previous 45 years somehow got into the
book I mean covering America covering
overseas covering Vietnam going all over
the world all these experiences which
have enriched me I think and also each
other the other books that I've done
because when I do my larger book is each
one is like going off to get a separate
graduate degree they take four or five
years so it's almost like on the first
day of the book you're knocking on it's
an education within itself you're
knocking on the door of a new graduate
school and saying let me and I'll come
here for four or five years I'll try and
master this subject whether it's foreign
policy of the media or competition with
the Japanese from the 1950s and in four
or five years I'll graduate now give you
this book as a boy I mean so all these
things I've been paid to learn for you
know if it's 46 years since I graduated
from college so I had this wonderful
career where I've been learning and I
think my work has gotten richer and more
complicated because I've encompassed so
much in the process of doing all this
next call from Boston go ahead yes I
want to thank c-span first I think
you're doing a good credible job for
this country I'd agree with that too
because there are many other outlets
where a serious writer can get a chance
to have a hearing these days in this
society mostly if you're a writer and
you get on television you're on for
about a minute
half and and you better have a book that
either is a book about how dieting or
something like that or how to be your
own best friend or something like that
it's got to be a feel-good book or a
diet book it seems to me I concur a few
quick points and then I'll hang up and
listen for mr. Alveston first I just
finished Rashid Taliban and Karen
Armstrong's Islam and I I would like to
hear something about I was shocked by
this what's going to happen at the end
with the oil consortiums when this war
is over what what role will they play in
the reshaping of Afghanistan another
point is I think it can't be expressed
enough that there was a judicial cool in
this country I like that
yes something about that and what about
this I consider a major fraud by Fox
Television Network being perpetrated
against this country calling themselves
fair and balanced but as far as Taliban
and I have this mental picture of this
one IP swelling mr. Omar at a 5-star
Hotel and you stand with Bush's oil
buddies it seems incredible to talk
about that I'll hang up then you well on
the Taliban and oil it seems to me that
one of the things we should be thinking
about is long range and we should be
thinking about our no long-range
security it seems to me that one of the
things that we've learned in the last
two months is that our alleged allies I
mean even those ney nations in in the
Middle East and it supposedly allies
whether it's Egypt or the Saudis they're
not really allies in the very strong
sense I mean the Egyptians whisked bin
Laden's family out of here without our
approval they have not been cooperative
and to our intelligence agencies or
pursuing the the routes and the
connections of the Allah
a Saudi nationals that were part of the
September 11th bombings of they've been
in no way cooperative and this is you
know American security is there and I
think we should be thinking long-term
about I mean here it is push is coming
to shove this is a very tough time for
us and they're not being cooperative so
we should be thinking in the long range
about being less dependent on Middle
Eastern oil for the sake of our children
for our security we should not have so
much invested in terms of national
security and people who really aren't
very sympathetic to us and aren't there
when it matters so it seems to me that
some kind of discipline change in energy
use maybe taxes on that will get us to
be more disciplined in our energy this
is something that should be really right
at the front of the table now so that in
the future we will have a great deal
more independence from those in the
Middle East who've turned out not to be
terribly reliable that would be the
first thing that comes to my mind his
second question was calling the election
results of judicial coup
well I think I mean I don't think it's
one it's not a great election it got
down there to a cliffhanger and if
you're in a cliffhanger and one party
controls the hierarchy the Republican
Party I mean if it had been in New York
or you know it's been in a state that
the Democrats had controlled everybody'd
be cheering the Democrats would be
cheering it happened to be a state with
a brother what the candidates was the
governor and he controls the state
operat and political operations and the
Democrats paid for it I mean they paid
for they were obviously very careless in
terms of the preparation of the ballot
and in checking out who was allowed to
vote I was obviously a mistake but the
truth is that Al Gore did not run a
really very good campaign I mean that
was that was the real problem and that
was what was mostly at stake in that
election I don't think of it as a
judicial cool I mean I think it's
heartbreaking election Frank for Gore um
and for the Democrats and you know I'm
sure there are people who feel that way
I just think you have to you know it's
Society had these election they're
probably been things like that before
the results are in there painful and
hard to take and then you get on with it
because this country can stop and walk
backwards next calls from New York City
mister halberstram I have great respect
for your work I served as a rifle
platoon leader in both the hundred and
first Airborne Division in another unit
but I have great respect for you then as
well to what time period thank you this
was 72 71 70 that's a very tough time
too because the war is winding down it's
post Ted and it's really ugly I mean
you're out there and it's not going to
work and the other side's really strong
and it's it's like being on a vigil when
everybody else is pulling up and leaving
am i right it was my question though is
I read McMasters book dereliction of
duty great book consideration Keenan's a
bright shining Lyle cesium and David
Carr has broken Vietnam and I understand
your position on war crimes
I mean clearly the military leaders
committed a dereliction of duty which is
a crime the Tonkin Gulf thought was a
criminal act and it is not prosecuted
should we just forget about this and
allow them to continue doing it I mean
Eisenhower warned us about the military
industrial complex Alison Carey
introspective thank you well first off
though when I talk about war crimes I
mean more crimes in the Nuremburg sense
I mean that the I mean I don't believe
in this I think these people made
catastrophic mistakes and
miscalculations and lied and continued
like that's why I'm so bitter about
McNair because I think his book is
deeply disingenuous tauf that long
period of silence if he's going to come
out with a book at the end he really has
to do a much more honest book and I'm
enough of a witness to know that he's
lying the book that he mentions on the
most important is a book he calls a
dereliction of duty as by a young army
majors probably not a manger anymore HR
McMaster and it is if you think I'm
devastating the best and brightest about
people like McNamara and Maxwell Taylor
he is approaching he has much more
access to certain material than I and it
is a book that has great resonance among
Terry men because it really Colin Powell
for example it shows how the Joint
Chiefs and the and the care and the head
of the Secretary of Defense played the
political game for Lyndon Johnson at the
expense of the military men in Vietnam
it is a devastating book
I don't believe as I say in war crimes I
think we I think I move that you've read
these wonderful books my colleague Neil
Sheehan is brilliant bright shining why
I think we should learn we should read
we should pay attention I think it's
important to read the McMaster book but
uh and I think you know you've done it
well and and we shouldn't lightly forget
how leadership can really take care of
itself and be and be really deeply
disingenuous not only what is doing but
then Farrow failed to be candid after
it's really a catastrophe we are halfway
through a three-hour conversation with
David Halberstam about his writing
career you can telephone us numbers that
will be on the screen throughout our
conversation or you can send us an
exactly mark can we get some more waters
or you know what parts you as you're
talking here and you can send us an
email at book TV at c-span org next call
is from San Francisco yes my name is
Scott Baskerville and I believe should
be required reading for your books that
people want to understand our country
and culture but I was curious if you had
a favored word and perhaps you could
share some of your favorite authors that
you've enjoyed over the years
well I've loved the writings of Graham
Greene over the years I mean his books I
think he's always been just a wonderful
writer one of the best books of on
Vietnam was the quiet American which I
used to reread about once a year I was
thrilled when VS Naipaul
won the Nobel Prize I think he's a great
great writer and particularly about the
underdeveloped world of the third world
I was once for the New York Times a
correspondent of in the Congo and
it's like witnessed events there and
Naipaul wrote a great book about the
Congo a bend in the river which is well
worth reading I mean he's just amazing
talent when I was young Teddy White's
book John Gunther's books were
inspirational you know people don't know
John Gunther today and are they and he
would do these inside America inside
Africa is a great reporter and he would
just vacuum information and his stuff is
never out of date when I was young there
was a book called the reason why by
sessile Woodhams Smith on why the reason
the the Light Brigade marched into the
valley of death and when I read that it
sort of made me want to write comparable
books because I read like a great novel
and I mean I just there I just finished
reading a wonderful book by a man named
Charles Baxter pub it's called he's a
professors and it's not his work of
fiction he teaches at the University of
Michigan and it's called a feast of love
it's just beautifully done lyrical book
I'm going to just enjoy it so much
they're just there's so much good
writing out there now I mean they're so
it's interesting there's so many
talented people out there writing better
and better and there's so little of it
ventilated into the modern media process
for whatever reason and the children you
reference the book called the American
and American dilemma yeah oh boy that's
a great book that's a I had graduated
from college in 1955 and remember I'm
someone who graduates without honors I'm
not a great student I'm a bad student I
think I'm in the bottom third of my
class and it intellectually I'm having a
hard time and I go off to Mississippi
and a young lady I know gives me a copy
of gunner and Murderdolls American
dilemma American Dogma which upon which
really the Supreme Court decision of 54
was a stand there I am in the small town
ten thousand people eight thousand
people in Mississippi and I'm working
every day out there on the street
covering people on talking to and then
at night I'm reading 30 or 40 or 50
pages of Myrtle and it's wonderful it's
beautifully written and it's a great
thing that happens if you're reporter
what you see out in front of you
connects to a book that you're reading
the book but the book gives an
intellectual and historical
background to what you're seeing in
daily life that synergy of life and
history comes together and I thought
this is wonderful and it's so informed
me and it's so enriched to me and it was
just it was a pivotal book in my life I
mean I later was able to write to mr.
mertle's daughter who was married to to
the president of Harvard how much that
book had meant to me I mean and that in
a gave me the beginnings of my own
intellectual growth I didn't have to
just only be a reporter that you could
that you could go and connect to works
of history and it and it turned out it
was intellectually very important for me
as Susan because I'm not good
intellectually in the abstract but if
you put me out where events are
happening I will devour books and at
least I did that now I'll devour a bit
more in the abstract and it was just
wonderful that I could go to this place
and suddenly have a hunger for learning
in the probably a book that I might not
have been able to read had I been back
in college you might not have been what
it connected to events and out of that
began my own real intellectual growth
our next call for you is from North
Andover Massachusetts your uncle David
Halberstam well good afternoon and again
thank you c-span I I just appreciate
this so much every every week and every
month when you have the in-depth Susan
you do a great interview mr. Hellerstein
I agree I agree yes thank you it's three
different quick questions one did you
ever have any connections in your New
York time with Buffalo New York do you
have relatives there no like I don't
really do you have any other children
besides the beautiful little girl that
we saw on the on the photograph that you
mention oh I don't but thank you for the
kind words okay and the other question
is do you believe that creative people
when you're mentioning your time at
Harvard creative students are done a
disservice by having some of these
standardized tests that you know are so
important for their future and don't
show the creative side of the human
being because the standard eye test and
eyes testing is for you know more of a
focused
serious individual who does just student
work it's a very good point to make out
I don't think it does a disservice I
think sometimes those of us who aren't
up to speed intellectually or have as I
did a learning disability which I didn't
know as a learning disability I mean I
didn't I didn't reckon we didn't know I
never heard the word dyslexia till I was
in my late 30s and this wasn't dyslexia
I'm not selected but I had clearly some
kind of problem with my concentration
and and might still have it I think
people like that who are not up to speed
or struggle sometimes can define
themselves as not being as smart as they
are they may be talented but they're not
and then there's another person who just
you know academic work is just a piece
of cake that it's like eating salted
peanuts they're very good they get high
grades they go to college they're magnet
with highest honors or some become some
but they don't have the originality that
turns into talent and we don't know when
we graduate from college we don't know
who's really talented we don't know
who's going to be original I mean
occasionally we do I mean I was at
college with John Updike and he was a
summa [ __ ] laude and he was even then he
was the braid up dying but a lot of
times people who are creative are
exactly well don't get good marks
because they're combative they're
outside
they fight conventional things and their
talent is going to take a lot of time to
show up most talented creative people
that I know don't get terribly good
marks when they're young next question
for you is about this book home and the
writer of this question says I've been a
student of yours for the past few years
in its absence eeeh and in my opinion
one of your best works was your
biographical project on ho very
to-the-point and uncomfortable to learn
the greatness of the man in retrospect
can you compare the type of
misunderstanding that the u.s. had
toward ho his motives in ideology with
the still evolving notions we have
toward the terrorist organizations such
as the Taliban and the symbolic
figurehead Ben
that's a really interesting questions
and the book is a small distilled essay
on Vietnam Vietnamese nationalism with a
small portrait of the life of Ho Chi
Minh in other words I fed his his life
and fed the nationalism into his very
slim it came out I believe in 1969 I was
as Viet Nam deep in the book I brought
out in 1965 making of a quagmire seemed
to me inadequate it was written when we
had about 18,000 Americans there and
about this to the time I started doing
this it were about 500,000 and I felt I
hadn't done it well enough I was
dissatisfied with my own with my own
work and so I said learn more and I
started and I did this little essay and
I by then I might - my history of
Vietnam was much more up to speed and
this is a good small I think valuable
book is not a big book or a rich book
but I think it's a valuable smart book
and we had at least our government had
demonized who I think who could have
been an ally of ours I think he admired
the United States and what we had and I
you know he was a communist but it was
much more a nationalist we could have
had a Tito like person there's George
Kennan kept pointing out I think it's a
very different with bin Laden I mean I I
think he's very talented very rich and
from day one he is for a variety of
reasons sworn to our destruction and
he's clever it would be great mistake to
underestimate him I I think he's I don't
think it's about Israel I think it's
about not limit it's about limiting our
power in the Middle East particularly
and did their by destabilizing these
moderate allegedly moderate our Arab
nations Egypt and Saudi Arabian
countries like that and putting in
Islamic fundamentalist
Berman's there i think he would be a big
power broker I think he's driven by a
passion for rasa tea of narrow viewpoint
and nobility a skill and a lot of money
and so far a skill in projecting his
ideas to some of the miserable of the
earth I mean one of the things that's
very important in this equation that we
don't entirely understand the effect of
is the importance of modern television
and how it heightens tensions between us
and that part of the world because
people who are really miserable in these
terrible countries which have not
modernized turn on television set some
of them and they see us being rich and
they see themselves being poor and they
make the judgment that they are poor
because we are richer which i think is
great the state they're poor because
they're poorly governed because their
governments for a variety of religious
cultural reasons fight modernity fight
science and technology of and fight
educational opportunity I mean they are
burdened by their own I believe cultural
blinders and in many of the parts as
well but I think that's why they're poor
they're not poor because we're rich but
the ability of bin Laden to sell the
idea that they are poor and miserable
because we're rich has been a great
great source of strength to him and this
is going to be a very difficult long
confrontation it's not going to be easy
as way away from the strengths of the
magnetic field of our power militarily
and in terms of intelligence the problem
I think it's I think would be a mistake
to think that the propaganda war which
we're doing very poorly but can be
readily righted I think for a variety of
reasons it's always going to be a very
hard kind of cell that we're going to
make on our better side to them I think
that we have to assume that we're out
there pretty much alone and we're
go into the face of a negative cultural
social attitude towards us and it's
going to be and if you put up the best
programming in the world with the smooth
spin doctors trying to sell American
ideas and attitudes and why what we're
doing to that part of the world it will
be very like really going into a storm I
think it's going to be very tough
Pablo Colorado good afternoon mister
halberstrom I'm much appreciating your
comment thank you
I could concern with the current
terrorism crisis I see a thousand years
of confrontation conflict and animosity
between Islam and Western civilization
my question has a Western bias but it
can the converse as an Islamic bias
question what aspects of Western
civilization and culture must Islam X
accept to ameliorate this animosity
confrontation or conversely what must we
in the Western civilization accept from
Islam to ameliorate the present
confrontation it's a very interesting
question it is possibly unanswerable I
mean I think what we have to have is
respect for each other
and an intelligent opinion of each other
I think and that may I mean we're we're
certainly not very good at understanding
Islam or that part of the world I mean
if you look at our portrayal of the Arab
world in our movies I mean it is really
a cartoon I mean where if you thought we
were bad on Asians back in the 50s and
60s I mean if you want cartoon view of
the world see how Hollywood and others
portray the Arab world I mean really
and over a very long period of time and
I think that means oh we start well
behind the curve I think because we're
an open society we can improve I think
it's going to be harder there because I
think the propaganda Wars the lack of a
free society does these are effectively
closed societies and the weather from
government or semi government-sponsored
sources the anti Western propaganda is
ferocious
the one thing I think we do have working
for us particularly with some people in
that part of the world is I mentioned
that they see us now I think there's a
lot of our society that is a very
attractive I mean to the young I mean
the informality of it I mean the way we
treat each other I think I think one of
the great issues that is at stake here
and is not talked about is treatment of
women I think one of the reasons that
the people who hate us hate us is the
importance and the rise and the change
in gender in this society the role of
women I think they when they turn on a
television station at CNN and a young
woman reporter is asking a tough
question of an older white male who's a
public figure and being fearless that is
startling to them and they don't like it
I don't like think they see toes and
they don't like the role of women in our
society and I think that's one of the
great blocks in changing that their view
of us and getting them to accept that we
have things that are attractive on I
think there's a real collision out there
and I think the fact that lines are
drawn now means it's not like I don't
think we're likely to get better about
them and I don't think they're likely to
get better about us next call is from
st. Louis
hi mr. Halverson great to talk to you I
run an educational website on studying
the Vietnam War using books and I highly
recommend best and the brightest it's a
brilliantly rich book wonderfully
written thank you I have a question you
in that book you do not references or
endnotes which you explain why you do
that and all your later books
so are you you have you do have detailed
records as you mentioned but your
masters great book which is unbelievably
detailed reference I wonder if you have
a could tell me how the the nature of
book writing on the Vietnam War has
changed in terms of almost requiring
such extremely detailed references to
document the resource well I think it's
not so much that it requires it but it's
available now I mean we're now we're now
26 years since the last American troops
left were 36 years since the critical
decisions to growing in a combat
incarnation were made so a lot of stuff
has been released there Johnson tapes
their tapes of the White House that are
there and I would have been glad had
that stuff been available then to use it
the the the reason I didn't put the list
of interviews in at the time was that it
was the height of the Nixon era where
they had done they were going after
people who'd done the Pentagon Papers
they were subpoenaed people I had been
called because I knew Dan Ellsberg and
had interviewed him I was in fact
subpoenaed and I was called in a court
case where if they they eventually threw
the case out but I was facing jail time
for just having known Dan Ellsberg was a
very different time and I did not they
were they were really doing some witch
hunting a bit then and I did not want my
sources to be I wanted my sources to be
protective and I end and I could not
give that list at that time I could in
retrospect now I mean I could but for
whatever reason it is now a done deal
and it would almost seem like tampering
with the book to add on in fact
posthumously in your in your current
book you do talk about who who I
interviewed and you note two people
would not talk to you Sam Nunn says that
that was surprising because I met him a
couple of times we seem to get on we had
a very nice day together once in
Nantucket
meeting of a bunch of senators and I
liked him and so and he was a person who
knew a lot about this because he'd been
in the Senate during the during this
period and I was willing to go down to
Atlanta and I made a lot of phone calls
and I find it any case and I got back
the word he won't do it and there was
never clear why and I think maybe he was
just pulling back from that part of his
life I wasn't I wasn't really clear as
to why and then of course Clinton
himself who when the war when when he
left I wrote me a note about something
else I wrote and clearly was when he was
taking a real pounding on mark rich and
his stock was at the lowest moment and
he and I'd written something that there
was critical but I think he thought in
retrospect taking all the other abuse
was more sympathetic and I got a nice
note from him saying let's talk so I
thereupon began to call regular I called
about six times hoping to get together
for the book and including one call to
Betty curry his personal secretary and
he never returned any call which I which
didn't surprise me I didn't think you
wanted to deal with the reporter who was
by then as well prepared as I was I
think the president by then or former
president like to deal with people who
hadn't done as much homework Mexico Co
is from Winston asari first Los Angeles
you're on so David Halberstam
good morning this gentleman Sam how are
you I'm fine w honey very well I've been
a big fan of your books for years and I
have a question in making of a quagmire
and I don't know the details I haven't
read it in probably 20 years two
advisers were sent to Vietnam to assess
our goings on there and the report back
to Kennedy I believe they were given
tours by separate people and I believe
that the upshot of the whole thing is
that Kennedy asked if they in fact went
to the same time young because there can
you discuss that real brief video I
think it was two people one was there
was a civilian guy and the military I'm
trying to think of who the civilian was
made whether it was Roger Hillsman or
someone like that and the military
person was
Brook Krulak who was the the military
guy on Vietnam and a cruel act currently
came back and you know said though
things are really going very very well
when clearly by then the war was very
was over my friend Neil Sheehan a later
got to know crew locking but crew lock
was later common down to the marine
corps um and and he was and his son was
coming down to the Marine Corps as well
Chuck on that's a I think Berg wasn't
comment and I know his son was a
certainly Brut got to be at least three
stars um he got to know my friend Neil
Sheehan very well when Neil was doing up
a bright shining lie and he swore to
Neil that he did not rig the thing that
he by the time he got to Vietnam in the
late fall of 63 and he did all this
interviewing of
the senior advisors there that but he
brought back was what they told him and
and that therefore he'd been been I
gathered bamboozled by them as well I
mean he shouldn't have been it should
have been should have been a way of
finding out and going to lower levels
that what we were saying was was uh that
what we were saying as reporters was
true and that the war wasn't going well
I'm a little suspicious of what the
senior crew lack said because he was
really someone who had really been one
of the people trying to destroy my
career and and spreading scurrilous
stories about me when I was there I
there was a time Time magazine in those
old days back in 63 had a little house
letter that it would used to put up and
it took a lot of gossipy stuff and it
didn't put in the magazine but I put it
into this insiders letter and one of the
stories there was that a was a cruel act
which is that quoting another reporter
that I had looked at a bunch of Vietcong
bodies and it burst into tears and that
was in the context of 1963 supposed to
be you know enormously destructive to
show me as a
as a wimp and a [ __ ] and a guy who was
not to be counted on as a combat
correspondent so I in fact grabbed him
at the airport I found out about red and
I said don't you ever put [ __ ] like that
out on me again I mean I really was
ferocious pyrrha superiors about that
because it was a scurrilous thing and it
was really designed to dim it to damage
your career the truth is in retrospect I
if I seen bodies of the Vietcong I
probably should have left I should work
for everybody I saw their next call a
question comes from winston-salem North
Carolina and sounds like we hopefully
lost them but let me go back to email
this is from a fella in Plantation
Florida re-grant who asked the process
question for you I'm curious if your
books always start and end on the
intended path or rather change direction
during your process for example summer
64 was as much social interaction and
racism as it was about baseball was this
your intention yes I think I mean the
answer is on both questions is data but
the books change a lot books have an
orbital thrust of their own and you
start a book thinking it's going to be
about one thing and then you get in and
it has a truth and you follow the truth
you bution you do very well not to lock
in on what you think the book is the
book begins with the question why did
such-and-such happen and then you follow
that trajectory but the trajectory can
change them and but let me go back to
October 64 when I done summer 49 it was
the last moment I was a previous
baseball book of an all-white air I mean
by Jackie Robinson had come aboard and
Willie Mays was about to appear but it
was essentially a white world in October
64 I did it in no small part because of
race because the Yankees while not
entirely lily-white had fought the
coming of the black players whereas the
Cardinals with a bill white Curt Flood
Lou Brock and in particular
Bob Gibson had opened the doors to great
black
talent and great black athleticism and
so I saw something symbolic there that
one team had used the new forces at play
at our society and one had resisted them
but you are always adapting in the book
when I began the most recent book um
born in time of peace it began by being
my being in a cocktail party in in the
spring of not two years ago ninety nine
and being with my friend les Gelb in the
bombing of Kosovo's going on and I asked
him who's driving it is it as the media
says Madeleine Albright and he says no
actually it's the Vice President Gore
and I think well that's really
interesting and I'm out of that loop and
I ought to know more about that but I
don't find out out so I called my friend
Graydon Carter in Vanity Fair and said
why don't I do a piece on who drove the
bomb he's a great idea do it so because
there's a magazine piece then I do a
little bit of reporting and I and I
realized this more than a magazine piece
that there's a really an interesting
question here are we a which I try and
answer in the vote are we a monopoly
superpower that is a de facto
isolationist nation I mean and if so how
and why did this happen and I start
interviewing more and so I go to my
publisher and I say let's make it a
small s a book to a book small s a book
thirty-five thousand words on they say
fine I'm it's not going to be much money
but we're working out so I do some more
interviewing and I begin to get the
shadow of Vietnam the impact of Vietnam
on two institutions vital to the country
very damaged I mean most of the rest of
us have gone on to our lives but it has
been very damaging to the Democratic
Party which has been out of power for
twenty of twenty four years and from
whose ranks came the architects and most
of the protesters and it has been very
damaging to the United States Army
because we sent a good in Korea we sent
over a bad army and got back a good army
in Vietnam I said of a good army and got
back a army with a virus I mean been
army : colorized very very well about
about you know the inflated metals
inflated promotions of the toxins that
got in because of the the wrong people
promoted he's the proudest of anything
he's done this in his public life on
helping to be one of the people who has
cleansed the army so I thought I didn't
seek the shadow of Vietnam but it's
there and I went to dinner about two
months into it with Bob Woodward and I'm
my colleague has done all these
extraordinary business reporting and I
and we're talking he says it's your
successor book to the best and the
brightest because I start thinking I
think he's right so that night I'm
staying at the Jefferson hotel yeah I've
got that I right under my computer with
me or printer I hand write a letter
about five pages to my lawyer agent
saying I have hit a mine a vein a good
rich vein this is a new book it is a
full book it tells what Vietnam has done
the shadow to all these things and I
mean among it's not just whether the
isolationist but it's how and wine it
would be a nom de I hand printed and
sent it off and they with this it be
goes from being magazine article to
small book to full book so you are
always listening to your Brooke I mean
the book changes and you have to adapt
to those changes if you go in people
tell you things you think I mean I can
tell you again let me give you an
example in the year September 2000 I
think the book is done I come down for
my final interview to Washington and I'm
going to see General Wesley Clark was
the commander of the American forces in
Kosovo we we and ur of the American
forces in Kosovo we we go we talked for
probably an hour and a half maybe two
hours I've forgotten the exact length
and I come out of there and I think the
book is done by now I think hmm
everybody commander of forces there and
he's been squeezed out and virtually
fired I've got to reopen the book so I
did six more months of mode of
interviewing based on that interview
that I wasn't there yet
you have to listen to your own book
Woody Creek Colorado under Thomson
country
yeah he's the neighbor thank you for
being on c-span thank you for having me
Bernard fall and what effect his books
had on you but I did know him he was a
wonderful colleague and a wonderful
friend there's a moment is somewhere in
the vast archives of the New York Times
there was a very angry letter I wrote
about Jane Fonda because there had been
a an article in The New York Times
Magazine as long after Bernard was
killed and someone had asked Jane Fonda
you know do you read this was in her bag
last Wednesday stage do you read what do
you read and she listed some people and
and the interviewer asked what about
Bernard fall I would have some real
condescending phrase about him and I
wrote one of the angriest [ __ ] critics
lines I've ever written in my life
Bernie fall was a great teacher to the
generation of Vietnam reporters that I
belong to Tennille - Peter - Charlie
Moore I mean he was a wonderful man he
was very brave vote for he what what for
he well he really wrote books I mean he
would write occasionally for magazines I
guess he was in the New Republic or
whatever and he was loved by the men he
you know he had the history of that war
was in his brain I mean he covered the
French war and he loved America he
taught I think here at Howard and in
Washington a wonderful man and he taught
the rest of us when about two years ago
my wife and I were back in Vietnam for
the second time since the war was over
we went I'd always wanted to go to Deann
bien phu and because that's the famous
battle and we got there and we walked it
and i'd really read bernard wrote a
wonderful book called
blanking out on his book on the NBN foo
but um death in a very small place great
book involved ambient room and I walked
the battlefield but I wasn't getting it
wasn't getting it and I stayed up that
night all night rereading Bernard on it
and then I walked at the next date and I
got it and I got it and we were there
and there's almost you know the
Vietnamese aren't very good at souvenirs
or battle monuments I mean they're not
this pretty primitive Society I mean
here's a place that is really like in
effect Gettysburg for their minds famous
place but there's not much but there's
somebody has farming roses there and
we're walking about it with a final the
cast Reese's headquarters are where
there is a little monument and there's a
Roseville and as women there and I buy
three roses from her and then I pressed
them in Bernards book on the way home so
that I have on my desk the dry leaves of
roses pressed in Bernards book from the
envienta which is one of most
heartbreaking battles on both sides the
French and the Viet Minh that one could
imagine the bravery of both sides and so
I mean I love Bernie he was a great
teacher he was held a very small place
is one of the great books on Vietnam won
a great battle accounts I mean we've
recently had some other ones Mark Bowden
doing Black Hawk Down and my friend
General Howe more joe galloway doing uh
We Were Soldiers Once and young but but
held in a very small place is really
right up there we're at the top of our
third hour of conversation with David
Halberstam were spending all this time
talking about his writing career next
call comes from Arlington Virginia hello
you're on the air yeah
hello mr. harvest amazing how much I
really enjoyed your books over the years
you and I have two questions for you
basically one is if you would maybe go
into a little bit more depth about what
your next project is you had alluded to
it earlier in the program
and the second question is about the
best and the brightest and as you have
said it that book came out of an article
for Harper's that you wrote on McGeorge
Bundy and I was wondering if you had
ever talked to McGeorge Bundy after the
publication of best and brightest and
got his reaction and can you describe
your relationship with him and do you
feel or if you had any sort of
relationship to with him prior to the
publication and you feel the same way
about him as you do about Robert
McNamara would you expressed earlier in
the show a lot of German alias as
angrily Bobby I thought he also remained
silent too long although gradually late
in life he did admit Bundy did that it
was a mistake but he did it rather
privately or in small forums and I think
that he was not as public in trying to
analyze what happened and when he
finally wrote he really didn't write
about Vietnam he wrote about disarmament
we didn't have much of a relationship
he'd been Dean of Harvard when I was a
student editor and we had dealt with
each other I wouldn't say with either
lack of affection or affection when I
was doing this book when I came back
from Vietnam um Scotty Reston who knew
him this was in 1964 and he was Bundy
was the head of the national security so
you ought to go over talk to Bundy I'll
set it up and the word came back Bundy
didn't want to see me I think it was
because he didn't want to maybe I was
contaminated or toxic by then and
considered too much of a pessimist and
this would hurt him was Lyndon Johnson
maybe he knew which way the play was
going when I was doing the best in the
brightest I thought he treated me with
great condescension and I remember one
of the two interviews I did and this one
was for the magazine piece and one was
for the for the book and I went to see
him and at the end it was 1969 it was
October of 1969 I think it was the Mets
were in the World Series as why I
remember it I said at the end why are
you silent why are you talking and and
he said well I'm not going to talk about
this and I said but you were the Dean of
Harvard you of this great intellectual
we all looked up to you this couldn't
Wars tearing this country
apart and you must speak out and he said
you're very arrogant and I said no I
think you're the one who's very arrogant
and we parted with great coldness and
didn't see each other for a while I
walked out of there it was very
interesting to me I'd always had this
great respect for what Bundy and people
like that represented the American elite
the great aristocracy Groton Harvard all
these you know secret society skull and
bones and I came out and I thought it
doesn't really mean that much does it I
mean he's he's letting this is this is
an enormous ly important moment and he's
going to stand on the sidelines and not
do anything then maybe he's not what you
thought I mean maybe you and your own
traditions are just as good I mean I
thought about my grandfather coming over
here from the old country and I thought
of my father who Adam been a medic in
World War one and then went on to
college and medical school very limited
resources put himself through and had
been a combat surgeon in World War two
and I thought of my own journey I mean
rather not a good student but going to
places like the South in the Congo and
in Vietnam and I thought maybe I know
more about the world that he does maybe
I've traveled more and seen more of the
underside I came away with less respect
for him and an embryonic beginning a
belief in my own journey but I knew
things that maybe these people that I'd
always taken so seriously because I got
such good marks or had PhDs or did these
things that maybe they weren't as good
as their curriculum view time and maybe
I was a little better than mine it was a
it we did see each other to answer your
question we really Auchincloss then he
buddy hated the book and he would people
he would much people brought up to me he
would mumble something like it's not the
Bible it's not the Bible
um late in his life there was a dinner
party where they all could cost the
wonderful novelist who knew him brought
us together and we got through the
evening I think we were both on
our best behavior but there was no
warmth and no feeling of the Bundys that
we have to get together with the howler
stands around the house and so we have
to get together with the Bundys
sometimes ahead caller
yes as a great fan of your work and your
ability to sort of deconstruct symbolism
in different periods of time I want to
kind of ask you to comment on in the in
the mainstream media maybe the lack of
courage or lack of outrage in regarding
the perceptions of militant Islamic
fundamentalism versus Islam in the way
that say KKK flies in the face of
Christianity and so forth you expand on
that a little bit I think a lot of
people would appreciate well whispers
let me do a disclaimer and that is I've
never worked in the Middle East I'm not
an authority on the Middle East I you
know I've never written about it don't
consider my mean I'm I'm low-grade
expertise I wouldn't even put the word
expertise and I don't know a lot about
Islam I mean obviously there is a fierce
force there within Islam that is driven
driven by poverty driven by anger
towards I think you know the corruption
perhaps of the Saudi royal family I mean
there's a lot to be angry about there
and there probably are people there who
look around and they are both angry at
what they think are the co-opted regimes
and they think those regimes have been
co-opted by the West as opposed to being
co-opted by them themselves for their
own narrow greedy reasons and they are
enraged I think because they see a
mighty religion from part of the world
where in their minds civilization began
and first flowered trailing in terms of
accomplishment the infidels of the
decadent West I mean I mean this this
dilemma if the West
is such a place of infidels if it is so
decadent why is it rich and powerful and
we in Islam are poor and often backward
and that is a dilemma that I think
enrages people and particularly I think
enrages the Islamic fundamentals now as
to your question about the media I think
there's been actually a lot of pent
between Islam and then this small rather
violent minority which killed Sadat and
would like and would like to do and
which I think threatens you know right
now the life of the the President of
Pakistan I mean I think which is a you
know swore its real enemies are in the
Islamic world not us our next call for
you comes from a military count Minot
North Dakota hey god bless you c-span
this is just wonderful and I'm a I'm a
football fanatic but here on Sunday
afternoon hobb Istanbul Trump football
anytime it's bitchin
that shows that the NFL is in really
serious decline thank you I just have a
couple quick comments I'll get off
because everybody wants to listen to you
talk I love to to to book treatments I
would love to see by mr. Hall burst em
one on the the Clinton presidency and
one on the career and maybe the UH
appreciation of Roger Maris thank you
all hang up a little thank you well we
have a North Dakota
you know connection in our family to
gene saneness halberstam is from Valley
City North Dakota she is I have to tell
you though Sarah she's a she's real New
Yorkers someone will be if the nearest
neighbor is about 10 miles away I I like
to joke if they if they ever close down
New York the last person crossing out
and leaving on the last bridge will
would be be my wife up I did write about
Roger Maris by the way at some length in
October 64 I mean as I make a very nice
portrait of a person a country boy who
is really ill at ease in the city and
also the first figure of the media era I
mean I think
Roger Maris's a pursuit of the Ruth
record was the first great event of the
new media television age and he was
uniquely ill-equipped to deal with it I
mean then the Yankees offered him no
protection now tell me what the first
part of the question was because I about
the Clinton presidency the Clinton
presidency there's a lot about the
Clinton presidency in war in a time of
peace it is effectively a book that is
really about the Clinton presidency I'm
in a great deal of it so I thank you for
your kind words if change publishers a
few times we always do and when I was
leaving when I was finishing up my
fourth book in a four book contract with
Random House and I was going anxious to
do a book on on a battle in the Korean
War up in the yellow in November 1950
which I wanted to do for a long time
the Random House didn't seem very
interested I didn't I think they thought
it wouldn't get me on Oprah and so they
weren't terribly interested so and the
people at scriveners were very
hospitable and have been and interesting
because they they took me really in a
way on blind faith and then this book
new book has done very very well so
they're I think they're very pleased and
there's some people who are rather
amused over to Random House towards the
powers there let me leave know that
Yellow River book over the years and
biographical interviews it keeps popping
up when are you going to get it since
well I was I've barely started and now
with these events the question is
whether I'm going to be pulled aside by
events because these new events are so
transcending that you're pulled to them
I mean it's very hard to do anything
else now if you're a journalist I mean
the events are so transcending and I'm
feeling pulled towards that good
afternoon
as a Vietnam era vet I was always
frustrated with Lyndon Johnson's
micromanaging of the war can you comment
on that and also if do you have any
thoughts on honor if Lyndon Johnson was
afraid to win the war
oh I don't think it was about trade to
win it
ward didn't work I think they
significantly underestimated be a
dynamic that the other side had the lack
of vulnerability to I mean they thought
it could be done with the architects of
that war particularly McNamara thought
that American technology could do it on
that of a particularly air power and
they underestimated a couple things one
how big the country is Vietnam is a very
very big country and 500,000 troops
looks like a lot but they get swallowed
up they underestimated what the
nighttime would do and the thick foliage
and then it turns out a third thing
which we hadn't even thought of which is
this amazing network of tunnels
I mean miles and miles and miles of
tunnels so that even if we were bombing
them they were able to you know open the
in certain areas north of Saigon not
very far away they were a they were they
were really brilliant engineering
structures not for people like you and
me we couldn't fit in very well but for
people you know 5 foot 2 or 3 and 130
pounds was the you know the air power
they we over bet on technology and what
we could do and the effectiveness the
second thing was we thought we overrated
our ally the son of the Vietnamese and
how effective we they would be and we
underestimated the ability of the other
side to keep replenishing I think that
we were we were losing about 10,000 men
a year and we thought then the people
with the architects like Bill Bundy
talked about tightening the ratchet on
the north they they were probably losing
a hundred thousand men a year it really
was probably ten to one but three
hundred thousand young men were coming
into the draft age so they could because
it was their primacy their war of
independence it was a war of luxury for
us they could cake and accept a hundred
thousand as we could not take the ten
thousand there was a moment in 1966 when
my great colleague harrison salisbury
got a
a visit to North Vietnam nice often
burned on the North Vietnamese Prime
Minister and they talked and found among
sent and how long do you Americans want
to fight mr. Salisbury one year two
years three years five years ten years
20 years we would be glad to accommodate
you they would pay that price or the use
of odd phrase Kennedy's we pay the price
bear any burden because it was their war
of liberation and we underestimated that
we underestimate we offer estimated what
the technology would do are you I have
tests as quickly because this is call
everybody but are you hearing those same
sorts of echoes when you turn on the
television today and you I think any
blithely nerve how long is the kind of
case well I think anybody who knows
about Vietnam and that was about
military power is nervous about from day
one about how well our high-technology
power how much how applicable it is here
we know the limit of a believe me :
Powell and the senior military no but
this is an enemy not lightly vulnerable
to high technology or and that even it
elite forces like the Delta units it's
going to be a very tough thing I mean I
I think the great danger for this
society I think we can do this I think
we're strong resilient I think we can
another word is win but I think we can
be the stronger force in this very
difficult thing ad but we need to be
strong wise and patient we are a society
of immediate gratification I think this
we're more but I think that's our with
the greater the immediacy the impatience
is our vulnerability I worry about this
the stock my the country is different
from what it was in 1941 it's a
different kind of enemy it's a harder
enemy to attack and to assault but the
society is much more connect the norms
as it drives it revs faster the the
stock market in in 1941 only to a
handful of Americans were on the stock
market you could have long-range goals
in the private sector you didn't have to
drive the stock
quarterly report so we have the market
makes our larger companies much more
predatory much more impatient the media
is much more predatory and impatient and
demanding of answers and demanding of
stories its advanced betide we talked a
little bit about the cable news channels
24 hours a day seven days gotta have
news gotta have this a lot of things
take time are slow there aren't answers
answers are complicated we don't lend
ourselves much to having people who talk
this way on we want people who will give
answers and give it quickly and give it
now and this is a real vulnerability and
this is by the way in bin Laden has
talked about this he thinks that we are
vulnerable because of our impatience
that we are more impatient said that the
Russians would be easier to fight
because they were more patient and we
are I think he's going to be proved
wrong but it is something that we should
be aware of for David Halberstam next
Decatur Georgia hello it's a pleasure
listening to David ever Sam and I fought
in Vietnam in 1966 and Marine Corps and
I was against a war while we were
killing those Vietnamese people and I
couldn't understand why we were there in
the first place
how and after the war I read it I read
that very book you were talking about
Helmand very small place by Bernard
Bernard fall and I read several other
books by him and he was like you
extremely objective and not a subjective
not spotting the Pentagon's propaganda
but extremely objective and I just
wanted to have a couple questions number
one was he killed by the CIA because he
was so objective in that war and number
two what's her stance on the Vietnam War
and number three how does that war
relate to today's war against
Afghanistan and Osama bin Laden well
thank you to someone who hasn't heard
some of the earlier conversation
well first off bernard was not
by the CIA I believe in 1967 he stepped
on a landmine there I could be wrong
that it was a landmine but I believe it
was but he was killed in combat there
and he he didn't have to be there he at
his point he was distinguished enough
that he didn't have to be outed in fact
on point he he went out on point because
that's who he was and he had a great
desk for knowing and for talking and the
legitimacy I mean of your war
correspondent or so on like Bernard you
get legitimacy by doing it you can't you
you can't stay behind and get in and and
and do it from the back back
headquarters because the people who do
it aren't going to respect you you only
way in one way you get the respect as
for Vietnam I just think it was the
wrong war at the wrong time the wrong
place a tragic miscalculation driven by
fears of the McCarthy period and a
certain hubris of who we were and how an
arrogance of power that our technology
would work as well and third I do think
it's quite different from Afghanistan I
mean I think we went 12,000 miles away
gratuitous lead to something that was
not a national security crisis did not
threaten us the Vietnamese were not
about to attack Los Angeles or San
Francisco or Hawaii I think it was a
major misreading of history and of what
and of the Dhamma and the domino theory
I mean this was a war of liberation and
we got in the way of their nationalism
whereas in the case of this is the World
Trade Center attack attacks an attack on
the Pentagon that is people attacking us
and turning the homefront into a war
front I mean that isn't it I regard that
as a de facto declaration of war on us
and I regard it as a threat to the very
fabric of our society to freedom for the
open society the ability to have a
something which is really cherished to
all of us the free society to move about
freely to do this with confidence that
you are ok going to be protected and
also that you know you're not bringing
ten documents to every place you go to
prove that you are you I
we're so lucky in this society we've
been so free we we're on our own
recognizance all the time and I like it
that way I'd hate to lose it so this is
a huge challenge to the way the free
society operates and everybody not just
in this country but I think in the world
has a stake in it because if the United
States can't deal with us all these
other democratic societies and these
embryonic democratic societies will be
proved to be vulnerable I know there are
a lot of people in Europe these days who
are sort of enjoying a little bit the
fact that we are being tweaked or hurt
or wounded we've been immune for most of
the carnage of the last hundred years
which has been so hard World War one
places like fared on World War two most
of the terrible things in the world have
really helped Mills where the bombing in
Oklahoma City was the biggest and that
was us against us I mean it was a
domestic terrorist until then was you
know we were spared the carnage
now the carnage has come home and a lot
of people are sort of slightly Wow it's
America's turn but I believe they have a
stake in our being successful because if
we don't make it a lot of countries that
are not as strong will prove to be
vulnerable we have just about a half an
hour left in our three hour conversation
with David Halberstam marisol seventh
inning seventh inning and not time for a
stretch though we have a lot of callers
Oxnard California you're next
hello mr. helps damn I'm really enjoying
your show and I must say I feel Susan
show which Susan show well it seems like
it's become your show in my mind anyway
thank you especially your take on types
of news coverage I mean I I just think
the television people really I mean
they're you know I mean Peter Jennings
is a high professional and he's really
good at but he's the only senior person
in the media anchorman who made his
bones as a foreign correspondent we have
turned inward so much that's something
that should have been almost a mandatory
part of a senior journalists curriculum
vitae and the most powerful nation in
the world which was to expend at least
five or six years overseas
different assignments so that you get a
sense of what the world is the others
haven't done it dan Rather did a tour
Vietnam but that really isn't being a
foreign correspondent Tom Brokaw came
right up an American career and it shows
and I mean they got in in the critical
years 12 13 years last year's they got
rid of their foreign correspondents
because it wasn't good for the ratings
and I think that that's outrageous
screaming I didn't mean to interrupt you
sir yeah he's gone let me ask you about
party politics for a minute last summer
we had our cameras at the Democratic
National Convention and you were there
you were on those speakers my guide it
was an old friendship with the gorse
family I was a young reporter in
Tennessee and Nancy gore Nancy gore
hunger was a pal of mine and so when I
had known the gore family and the vice
president forever so when I so when I
was asked he asked would you know would
I come and be part of a group trying to
validate his background I said yes I
wasn't something I terribly much wanted
to do because I write book I mean I'm
most into daily joy I was a New York
Times reporter I couldn't do it because
I write books I have the freedom to do
it anything he called it a chit and I
answered do you worry about people
thinking differently about your books
make my book speak for themselves I mean
I think I refer in the book to him
running a clunky campaign so I you know
I think I'm independent and I think I
was sitting there talking about the kind
of background he had I would have
probably all things considered a
preferred not to do it but he they had
they had them because they had been very
nice to me when I was a young man going
way back you know it is 42 years I
covered I covered the the senior course
run for reelection in 1958 and I just
thought my own reputation for integrity
wood wood wood wood went out and I would
you know when I wrote about things if I
wrote about the mind write about the
street I mean I don't think anybody who
reads this book is going to think that
I'm a prisoner of the Clinton and Gore's
in fact I got a a rave review in The
Wall Street Journal which is usually
uses me for target practice John layman
former secretary of Navy wrote a very
very admiring
a review which said how honest I had
been about what you know the core people
on their national security people had
done in that decade this is David
Halberstam current book available in any
bookstore you walk into around the
country Warren a timeless piece and as
we listen to our next call most going to
show you another project he's associated
with it's just come out we only have a
proof coffee here but it is a book about
September 11th in New York City let's
listen to a call from Long Island
California hi this is Long Island New
York sorry okay thank you hi Susan it's
a great program and mr. David this is
just an opinion I don't know if you
agree with me or not but before I like
to say one word before I say the Muslims
and Arabs and the situation now very
sensitive especially for the people
who's living here and before we say that
hate maybe it's not hate maybe it's
anger we put ourself as a security guard
in the world it and they don't hate us
because they look at us as rich and they
are poor they look at us as helpers and
they look at us as people who help all
the time who's in bhavati or problems
and they look at us a solution not as
somebody to hit us and kill this is the
way they look at us as Americans in
other countries and before we say about
women and men and all these
relationships because maybe they are
happy the way they are we don't know as
you said mr. health and that you never
visited the Middle East maybe you have
to before we say our opinion about these
countries we have to go there visit
there and be mix with them or maybe talk
to people who's living there from the
United Nations the United States and
United Nations base maybe they are happy
the way they are III don't think
touching time I mean I think there's
some things they're happy
I think there's some things I see of us
on television but they find attractive I
think the informality I think that they
and the fact that we are rich I think
and they are poor has allowed the people
who say the fault
in their poverty the reason for their
poverty comes from us that we are the
cause of their poverty I think it makes
them unusually vulnerable to that kind
of propaganda I think that that the
people of bin Laden and other people
have exploited the difference in
economic status very skillfully in all
this is some photographs you don't
really have to comment on other people
are curious about your writing life and
these are a series of photos from your
work in New York City where do you do a
lot of your research well I mean I do
most of my research you know
interviewing but there's a wonderful
libraries in New York society I believe
I have a couple books out right now that
are overdue which I'll try and get back
to the motel there probably look at it's
a wonderful library old-fashioned
private I love going there it's a
brownstone on 79th Street you and we
also have photos by Brian lamb I do
believe that's ideal I that's eate i
Zabar's wonderful food place on about
80th and 85th and Madison and I like to
go there after I've worked some time for
by Deena cappuccino Brian wanted to
share cappuccino with me identity I
should say that these were all taken as
part of our first book notes book which
was a collection of authors and mr.
house Jim's book was featured in that
Santa Cruz California you're on for
David Halberstam well thank you very
much for c-span it's been wonderful I'm
a first-time caller any time any place
not a question when you mentioned
Bernard Paul in 1965 I was teaching
civics in a high school here in
California and I remember a chapter in
one of his books concerning a meeting
Cardinal Spellman's apartment in New
York City in which Kennedy and Mike
Mansfield and I believe it was Allen
Dulles Azur maybe John Post Ellis's son
who was a Monsignor to ha Spellman were
the purpose of the of the meeting was to
promote the diem
has the people that we should back and
Vietnam and I haven't heard very much
about that since then particularly Mike
Mansfield opposition to the war when he
seems to been in on the ground floor
thank you very much I'll call take
control
well yeah Bernard wrote about that a
number of us did there was in the early
days of Vietnam and the anti-communism
of the mid 50s in a country that was
essentially confusion - Buddhists
because of the French experience there
was a Catholic minority and it ended up
having a and of course it was more very
anti-communist in the country as a whole
and it ended up being a rather powerful
law before it in this country in the
particularly in the 1950s anti-communism
and Mike Mansfield who was a wonderful
man died a few years ago maybe as good a
public person as we've ever had I mean
wonderful wonderful man Mike long around
great deal on this was part of it
thinking you know this guy in the NGO
dinh diem and then ago family was the
best ticket and it turned out that they
were rigid and hierarchical and they
ended up being a sort of Catholic
Enclave in us southern country and they
were people who in a time of
Revolutionary War when Howe and these
people had driven the French out GM and
people like that had stood on the
sidelines so they didn't really have any
we kept talking about him as being a
nationalist but he stayed out of the
country and if he liked talking about
George Washington as a national as if
he'd by the way exited and stayed on the
sidelines and gone to France during the
Revolutionary War Doug Perry of Fox
Island Washington wants to know what has
been the most satisfying writing
experience for you
well mr. Perry I think it's the totality
of the career I think I think the great
privilege to voice 46 years as a
journalist I mean I'd agree coverage
we've been able to cover the earliest
civil rights little mentee to be a young
reporter in Vietnam when I think being a
reporter meant was so important because
the government was saying one thing and
we were saying another and I think when
when the government doesn't tell the
truth in journalism gets really
important and then now for so many years
writing books the ability to take a book
and something serious and spend three or
four or five years doing it and have
this sort of covenant with your readers
that if you do your work well and make
it accessible I kind of make my books
accessible they're they're not written
for PhDs they're they're written for a
serious lay people and on I love the
resonance if we had what we've had for
the last two minutes hours because these
are people who I mean these are all the
homes I've gone in confer 30 years
serious nice ordinary lay people have
been calling it the Covenant I've done
is that if I work my side and bring you
a story and try and be straight and make
it a good story and anecdotal and give
you perceptions and and help you to
understand the complicated world you're
in that you'll stay loyal to me and and
remain a reader and you'll have me in
your house that's a great great
privilege to be a free reporter in a
free society at a time when journalism
is gone far more corporatized to be a
mob post or going out every day kind of
sometimes refer to myself as a rich
man's lovely moment or develop my you
know shoot Death of a Salesman shoeshine
and a smile I'm a little better off than
Willy but I mean I'm one person I make
my own phone calls I get on airplanes
and fly out to see people and they take
me in and they talk about it I can't
think of a a more fulfilling career I a
richness of it I mean so Mr Perry's
question is it's really the sum of it
and in what I what I like Susan is what
it's done for me I mean I think I'm a
Richard you know I see that kind of
callow young man it started out we had
some of the photos from early days of
Vietnam and a skinny and black haired
and whatever and I see the changes in
the richness of the light and it's from
the friendships and it's from the
learning curve it's from going out and
interviewing all these people and you
get to be a richer wiser person our next
call for you is from Naples
California go ahead caller
are you saying you're going to mention
that about the September 11 oh yeah yeah
I think that's report because I'm a
cameo in that but it's such a beautiful
book okay it's Magnum photographers let
me let me do this because I've got
Naples so it enables you there all right
we do have lost them so let's go to
Magnum photographers look at Rome would
lose Naples oh my they called I mean a
magnum is a you know a group of great
photographers starting going back to
Robert Capa some extraordinary people
and it's a you know consortium with
photographers and they asked me about
three or four days after September 11th
they'd brought these brilliant
photographs what I write an introduction
I'm a Cammy on this but the photographs
are dazzling and I'm very proud to be
part of this as I'm proud there's
another book that I wrote the
introduction to correctly which I think
maybe I'm as proud of anything that's um
my friend horse Faust was really
critical in that and it's nothing but
photographs by photographers who were
killed in the Vietnam War including
people like Bernard faller in their
honor II who had to Larry burrows
beloved friends that book is so
beautiful of all the things that I'm
part of I can't think of anything that
I'm prouder to be part of well I'm told
that maples is there so we'll look at
some of the photographs of horse paws as
we listen to the teenaged impatiens over
the horse tomorrow and we'll listen to
this caller go ahead please yes thank
you for the opportunity to address
mister Halberstam I was a graduate
student in 1967 1967 I worked a lot with
gene McCarthy in the Philadelphia area
and at that point in time we really were
as a gathering forces to effectively
oppose the war my question really deals
with Robert Kennedy of the Tet Offensive
occurred in Jerusalem
right and effectively we we effectively
thought that we had carried the water
essentially and that the perhaps mr.
Kennedy would we didn't consider perhaps
an opportunist I was wanting your
opinion concerning that well I liked
gene McCarthy and I liked
Bobby Kennedy I was very fond of Bobby
Kennedy I think McCarthy went in first I
think Kennedy made a mistake in not
going in earlier and I think when but
when the Tet Offensive happened in Bobby
gun and he took a lot of hits for coming
in more slowly but I think he also gone
and I think rightfully that he could
approach far broader and create far
broader constituencies than gene
McCarthy did and there was always a
question of you know how hard gene
McCarthy was willing to work in that
particular campaign when he really
campaign hard enough to bring that home
and I know there's still a lot of
bitterness on the part of some of the
McCarthy people towards Robert Kennedy I
I thought they both were extraordinary
he along with Howe one of the few people
to get specific treatment from you in a
book you know a small book I did a small
book after the campaign on Robert
Kennedy next call is from Irvine
California
you're on for David Halberstam I'm mr.
Halberstam you talk a lot about the
difference between wealth in the United
States and in the Middle East and I was
wondering if you've ever given any
thought to how wealth is created and why
the United States is by far the
wealthiest nation that has ever existed
and had my own views on how wealth is
created but like to hear yours and
whatever United not splinting I ponder
all the time and I you know what are our
blessings that have done this obviously
the the size of our land the climate the
richness of the soil the fact that we
were very long time self-sufficient in
energy when that was more important than
we had copper and all these things I
mean the climates not to be
underestimated aside the landmass but
more recently landmass and mineral
wealth is is far less important I would
think that it's the dynamic of the
society the tempered capitalism the
immigration policy which makes us renews
us all time I would put in a factor of
our great land-grant universities I
think that you know we have Harvard Yale
Princeton and
the British have Oxford Cambridge and in
London school and a French how they
called Polytechnic and Sewer bummer we
have Ann Arbor Champaign Illinois we've
got you know Lafayette Purdue and Ave
had University of Indiana Bloomington
we've got the California system the
great universities like the nation of
California we've got all the schools
around Boston I think the ability in one
generation to rise above your parents in
this society the fluidity the
meritocracy the lack of hierarchy is the
I think we more than any Society summon
of the talents more of our talent of our
people I think you can be in this
country of who you want to be the person
of your dreams more like more likely
than any other place I I think the
combination of I think is our openness
our immigration policy our great great
land great grants state universities I
just think that we are sort of blessed
in that and it makes us regenerative so
that even after we end an area era where
the blue-collar economy turns into a new
high-tech or we end an era where
agriculture was so much more important
or and an era in which mineral work
value was so a minimal resource was so
important we keep being rich and strong
and I think we have I think a lot of it
really is from the the university system
and the immigration system and the
openness and the the tolerance it feels
in the freedom I think our freedoms I
think the freer we are the stronger we
are and the richer we are now that
sounds simplistic I mean a lot of people
there are a lot of people out there who
want us to have less freedom in the own
society think oh there's too much debate
or there's too much of this oh there's
too much this on television or whatever
but in the end it's our very freedoms
it's the First Amendment which isn't
just applicable to you know what the New
York Times prints it's it's a larger
thing that we are who we want to be and
that I think turns and morphs right into
the private sector I think more the
interesting things about the 60s
everybody a lot of people critics
conservative critics were very critical
about the sixties what they think this
is terrible time in America I think it
had a great effect on the private sector
I think you know from the era I went to
school in where you know if you wanted
to go into private sector you went into
one of five or six big companies us deal
or 4G general General Electric General
Motors and then suddenly the winds of
change of going out and starting up your
own company in the sixties swept through
the private sector as well we got a much
more explosive economy in the 70s and
80s I mean that's my own personal
feeling there is a question from Don
valor to Fremont California and it gets
us into one of your books having talked
about he asked what is the defining
moment of the 50s I might also ask why
was it important to write about that
decade what I think it's a very I mean I
just want to write that book because I
grew up in the 50s I went to college in
51 I graduated in 55 I covered the early
civil rights thing I met Elvis in 56 I
guess in Nashville I covered Martin King
and in 55 56 I covered the Emmett Till
trolley I saw all these things happen
and I think so much of what happened in
the decade of the 60s was seeded
prepared in the decade of the 50s so I
thought it'd be interesting as someone
who is becoming more of is going to go
back into the roots of these things and
find out what they happen defining acts
a couple things I would think one would
be Brown versus Board of Education in
1954 I suppose the moment when Ed
Sullivan says that he's never going to
put Elvis Presley on and and Elvis goes
on in 19 it's around 57 he goes on the
rival Steve Allen show which is never
beaten Ed Sullivan and Steve Allen has
these high ratings and Ed Sullivan
surrenders and immediately puts Elvis on
and the best the beginning of the
popular culture in a youth culture I
think these are a couple they're
probably about four or five others but
throw those out war in Pennsylvania go
ahead I have a both a suggestion and a
question the suggestion is that I would
look forward greatly to your doing a
book on Turkey where they have made a
tremendous attempt to combine Islam in
the modern world that's the suggestion
it's interesting idea is it nice and
said I like the way you phrase that I
think it's an interesting point can you
bring it in I mean it's a very good
description go ahead and my question is
especially in light of your comments
about the universities do you think it's
time to bring the ROTC units back on - I
really never thought they should have
left I'm a dissenter I'm person who
really doesn't I mean I know the
military likes the idea of an
all-volunteer aeon army but I thought
the draft was a democratic thing I
thought it was good for all Americans
and some I hear all Americans young
people to have some sense and larger
obligation is public service whether you
know it's military or something else in
a hospital whatever I think that it's a
healthier thing I never thought ROTC
should have been booted off the campuses
of Harvard or Yale I think it's a good
thing I think that the more you have
officers from all over the country the
better it is I happen to admire greatly
the senior military men they've been my
phrase friends I really like how Moore
who wrote We Were Soldiers Once and
young I like : pal I like Jack Galvin
who was a four-star and sacked your and
later Dean of the Fletcher School I like
John's I mean we have rich it's not just
the grunts I knew and the young officers
in Vietnam the senior people we turned
out John Salley country oh these are
very superior man and the more we get
them from all schools and including our
elite schools to better for everyone
Portland Oregon your question I yes I
want to thank c-span - for its
presentation here and my question or
comment and I like mr. Halverson - a
comment on this is that I have a feeling
that our history in the post-world War
two ERA fighting communism and what now
we have supported his foreign policy
some of the most
Nicias dictatorships that really are
really rude to their own peoples and
whatnot all in this all in the way of
fighting communism whatnot and and also
knocking socialism and whatnot as is has
been expressed in Western Europe the
whatnot and I was wondering as a
possibility what we did in Japan in
reforming property rights and allowing a
redistribution of property rights I read
that book the bright shining lie and
this guy john paul van was was saying
that this is what needs to be done the
reform of property and destroy
distribution of that in vietnam it
didn't do that and that would have given
the that would have given the well let
me jump in because our time is running
out and i think that you know all this
little water under the bridge there was
a lot to talk about land reform in
vietnam and man named wolf ladder jin
ski had gone over there we had done
we've been rather i think effective in
the philippines in and in and in japan I
think in our post-war stewardship I
don't think we did anything more
effectively now Europe and Japan was
very in Vietnam the forces against us in
terms of land reform were just too
powerful there was a lot of talk and not
very much got done and I think the other
the dynamic of the other side was just
too powerful they had a whole data
titled to the nations nationalism and
the people who were our allies I
remember the American advisers in the
early days in 62 63 these nice young the
gala Terry and all captains and majors
and go out and talk to their counterpart
about being you know going out and being
with the people and being more
democratic and changing and didn't
understand that most of their
counterparts were upper class would have
fingernails that long as a way of
showing that they didn't mess with the
ordinary people they didn't want to
narrow the gap between themselves and
the peasants more often than not they
wanted to widen it and so we were
sitting there Lavar egalitarian spirit
and no one was listening whether which
is one of the great lessons and
something that is so easily thrown out
the phrase nation-building well do
nation-building well nation-building its
nation-building has to come indigenously
nations have to build themselves you
can't come in from the outside and say
oh they're going to teach you nation
build I mean they either do it and they
indigenously have an instinct of how to
modernize themselves or it can't be done
I mean we can and often it can't be done
because the forces in charge don't want
to modernize because if they modernized
they will put their own rule and source
of power at risk the third leg of your
power study the reckoning how does it
look to you given the fact that Japan
which is the other half of the equation
has had their economy tanked well it did
I caught them on the rise when they
challenged us and we were doing a lot of
things wrong I was the hardest book I
ever did because it was really an alien
subject and and it's hard to write about
in that in the book I you know I was
going to print out one year there The
Wall Street Journal did a check of any
400 CEOs and it was chosen as the they
thought the best book on business that
here I mean what happened Japan had this
great run flattened out and is now
having some of the problems or more
serious problems than we had at the time
at that time they had but their quality
products had caught us when we were
asleep and they had challenged us to go
back and be better than we were and it
and be as good as we used to be there
was a moment which I was writing about
where they seemed to be in were the true
heirs of the original Henry Ford in
terms of high quality manufacture our
times of operating next call for you
comes from Chicago um yes first let me
say thank you susan and c-span for
allowing me to ask this question and
even though I haven't gotten my tours
done for Sunday and enjoyed this
beautiful day I am very happy to learn
more about mr. Halverson and look
forward to reading what will be my first
novel of his my question on the preface
it could be based on just anger after
the September 11th incident as well as
confusion at the purpose of
the big weapon we have and I haven't
heard this question and I'd like to hear
your comments on why if this is not the
intent of the use of this weapon why we
have not and if it had riots which
webinar is ours questions yes sir what
you talk or think on okay that's right I
think we the reason we don't use it is
very simply a minute it's inapplicable
and we would kill so many civilians and
if you wanted to pass on to your
children and mine and everybody else's
children an Islamic world where
everybody hated America and was sworn to
get revenge in their lifetime then you
wouldn't want to go ahead and use the
bomb if you want to try and have a world
where in some way you can have some
degree of mutuality of respect and
diminish this kind of act of terrorism
and even if we are not loved we will be
respected and and not have a sworn enemy
there then you are much more disciplined
in your use of force but if we use the
atomic weapon we will take this thing
and we will do their recruiting for them
for the next 50 years in one strike well
it's California yes first I'd like to
pay tribute to your guest for his book
the unfinished odyssey of Robert Kennedy
which I thought captured that era very
well and I guess my question is somewhat
related would he compare the sort of
marketed presidency or the marketed
politician versus the civic politician
of that time well you know you get in
you're going to get into a different era
because I mean the Kennedys were the
first people who really knew how to use
television they that John Kennedy was
our first television president
understood the camera understood how to
do it and since then we've really become
I mean the television is taken over and
it is more more when I started out as
young
Porter I mean when Kennedy went out to
run for the presidency he really covered
them in the field and you watched them
with people now it's all done by
television it's all sort of artificial
even when they go out into the interior
of the country it's always a television
stage and it's artfully arranged where
they'll be popular where they'll get a
good background people in native dress
or something like that or a Jimmy Carter
going down the Mississippi River on an
old steamboat or something I mean it's
all about a television stage so it's
increasingly I regret to say artificial
I don't know if you get into the
business of rating presidents but in the
50 years that you've covered in your
journalism here can you say when is the
time that Americans had the most
effective leadership in the White House
hmm
well I mean on the presidency I mean I
think Truman really I mean he I think he
was out of office budget I mean I was a
young college journalist in his latter
days I think he was obviously effective
I think Eisenhower was always underrated
you can't really judge John Kennedy
because it's a meteor he was so bright
talented and he was struck down we never
got the second term I think he would
have been a very good president with a
second term Lyndon Johnson was impaled
upon his hubris in the war so things
that he did in civil rights and and in
the Great Society never really are going
to counterbalance his his weaknesses his
strengths are always going to be
overshadowed by the tragedy of the war
Nixon had all that talent and strategic
sense but a terrible vulnerability and
insecurity and anger raging out at
ordinary people often people who had
elected him and
and voted form so I mean I think that
the technical skills were or were
diminished by the emotional ones I think
Gerald Ford is a much underestimated
president who wasn't really the country
on something - I mean I think he was a
good and decent man and was you know an
accidental president who was reflected
many of our better qualities and didn't
have that manic obsessive quality that
you need to be bidden that you know need
I mean where they didn't that the
glandular since he's so dominant that
everything in life is given over to
being president I mean there was so I
think one things I like about Ford was
the normality of a Jimmy Carter so
bright and a really other good
politician until he got into the White
House with the point he sort of decided
that he was above politics a number of
things that we ought to be started to
Camp David process which is a big big
plus did the Panama Canal I mean can you
imagine at the haughty hot button issue
in 1976 when Reagan ran against Ford was
the Panama Canal it seems awfully
trivial now Reagan is just you know an
American indignant to me I mean all
kinds of people got him I didn't get him
but obviously I never thought
post-vietnam we were weak and post a
sovereign I mean I just thought Vietnam
was a mistake I didn't think the country
was weak but a lot of people in the
country thought that was weak and so the
idea of Reagan has you know it's still
morning in America obviously he reached
ordinary people in a way in this country
and hit notes with them that I didn't
understand so I stand back and almost
admiring Lee just think that's one I got
wrong I mean I never would have
understood Reagan I didn't understand
his relationship with the ordinary
American people by god he really had
and he made them feel better in America
about America at a time when America
they didn't feel so well about America
and Bush tended to be underestimated I
think in qualities because he's not
verbal and I mean language was difficult
he could not articulate things but I
think he will probably end up getting
higher marks than his contemporary of
graders are inclined to give and Clinton
is going to be as rich a vane to mine
for historians as Nixon because you've
got all that talent all that skill and
it's going to be because of the win ski
scandal the presidency that might have
been I mean people are going to sit
there and debate it they're going to
look at that talent they're going to see
all the ability the naturalist he's
probably the most naturally gifted
politician that one has watched in the
sense that Reagan had great great gifts
but he was also riding away to help
drive the wave of the country becoming
more second serve ative the affluence
the demographic change affluence moving
from the Northeast to the south and
southwest Clinton flew in the face of
powerful demographic changes I mean he
was really going against a powerful
current I mean so the skill are enormous
and in the end the evidence and degree
of achievement is going to be
ferociously debated we're going to end
with a call because the times on the
south because we do that did we'd run
down the presidents okay on that one
thank you tickets do we leave anybody
out I mean you did not leave anyone out
the coast of Florida you're left go
ahead yes I'm on the towson yeah this is
rapidly from robert whitey reed from
Tequesta Florida former major league
baseball born and reared most of my life
in st. Louis Missouri in 1947 I was with
the st. Louis Cardinals when the book
when Dodgers came to Sportsman's Park
and Jackie Robinson who has been trained
of the mean
neither captain in the army and his fast
a background with his brother running
second to Jesse Owen in 1936 and the 200
meter dash for that against the fascist
German they'd off Hitler
I saw a strike amongst my ballplayers
put down by the owner saying that we
would bring into Columbus and the
Rochester team and replaced them
point-blank fired with no retribution
however they said we'll play and they
have some infect is it Jackie Robinson
who I think is the most courageous man
that ever lived is the silent a he did
call heard and played so hard but my
point was this I'm really right now the
Golden Age by gore Vidal I'm reading
William Turner's of rear view mirror and
the triumph Angier question is but my
question was this on September 11th my
beloved City New York
I took the ten volumes that this Burns
put out about our history of New York
from 1620 up to the building of the
Empire State Building and I used to go
down and marvel at that punk oh we're
still there we're stronger than ever
it's we're resilient come visit us it's
a great time to come to New York we're
not always warm and fuzzy and and
generous but this is a good time people
are being we found strength in each
other the more you're out with other
people the better you are
New Yorkers are being very hospitable
these days other than I suppose if
you're from Seattle Oakland or or Korean
pitcher for the Diamondbacks but it's a
terrific time please come and visit the
mayor has done I think a brilliant job
the taxi cab drivers are almost polite a
lot of our best restaurants are pretty
easy to get into the theater I don't
often do commercials but I if you're a
New Yorker you're really proud of the
city right now you're proud to be from
New York you're proud of this country
and the resilience of the firemen had
been just magnificent to Copsey so this
is a very good time to feel to see the
strength that great resilience of
ordinary Americans
and the nice thing with that caller in
his memories we managed to cover much of
what you call the arc of your career
from sports to race relations to New
York City in a rich 46 year career well
thank you for sharing
we got to the ninth inning and this is
the current book we encourage if you
haven't read David Halberstam answer
this conversation to sample some of his
work in war in a time of peace available
in bookstores now and our thanks to you
for watching and for all those great
questions we had